foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
I don't know
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
all right
[Music]
land of fjords Majestic mountains Cliffs
and waterfalls
in addition to studying geography Norway
is home to the greatest chess player who
has ever lived Magnus Carlson
since 2013 Norway has also hosted one of
the strongest chess super tournaments in
the world and it is one for which Magnus
has claimed the top prize in the last
four years
can anyone stop him
this time he'll meet one of his toughest
Challenges ever at his home tournament
with nine Rivals all hungry to beat the
best
from Carlson's fiercest online rival
today in their first classical
over-the-board battle in nearly four
years Hikaru Nakamura
to the young star Carlson once
hand-picked as his most worthy
Championship opponent alireza farrugia
two more young stars are trying to
follow in his footsteps laude Beck Abdul
sotorov and kukesh domaraju
to established stars have already won a
Super tournament in 2023 Anish giri and
Fabiano caruana two more long-time
Headliners seek to take their next turn
Atop A major tournament Wesley so and
Shakira mamat yarov
finally Carlson's Countryman and friend
ariantari rounds out the field who will
come out on top will Carlson run the
table yet again or will someone else
usurp the throne this is Norway chess
hello and welcome to round seven where
the tension is mounting Fabiana caruana
has a commanding lead only three rounds
are remaining so every move will count
let the chase for first place commence
I'm your host International Master
Ivanka houska and as always it's been a
wonderful pleasure to be here in the
Stavanger Studio calling all the action
alongside the legendary Grandmaster Judy
Polgar and the Fantastic commentator and
Grandmaster David Howell now Judah it's
been a dramatic few days lots of twists
and turns but for the chasing pack what
do they have to do to secure those wins
in the classical games
well it's very difficult that we've seen
for some time as Magnus for example did
not win a single classical game we see
that Fabiano is doing extremely well at
the same time everybody is getting tired
because it's already around seven you
have all all these interesting moves and
the Miss opportunities and blunders
whatever behind you but still you have
to be very strong and for Fabiano of
course he has to stay strong at the same
time for example if he's losing and
Nakamura can take the lead absolutely
and Fabiano has a two and a half point
lead I have a Hikaru Nakamura I mean how
can Fabiano maintain his composure to
keep that lead Yeah It's Tricky Ivanka
does he play it safe maybe take a draw
in the classical but lose some of his
momentum or will he just keep on full
steam ahead and just take those risks
we've seen it before he's been leading
throughout the tournament Fabiano but
two games ago he slipped he lost with
the white pieces and it would be
disaster if that happened again it's
it's not easy he's caught in two minds
we'll see his approach today absolutely
and we do have to take a recap of
yesterday's results because there was a
lot of fun to be had on the tables there
were four armageddons and Fabiano
caruana actually scoring a massive
combat win in the classical game to take
three points against nordebec Abdul
sotorov so Judy what were the highlights
of you yesterday
well I have to tell you that I was quite
amazed how gokash was playing the he
felt like comfortable he was the one who
was trying to push in the classical game
also at the end and of course the
Armageddon for example it was amazing he
had five pass born yesterday so that was
maybe one of the the interesting thing
because I'm very happy to follow and to
see unfolding such a talent as good
question yeah he's just 17 years old and
for you David there were four
armageddons on the table do you think
anyone will have felt that their luck
has changed well there's a few people
who will be cursing their luck but for
those who are on the upward Trend I
would say Hikaru Nakamura second place
in the world briefly just for one day
he'll be aiming to get that back today
of course uh but he's been playing well
yesterday defeating farouzia in the
Armageddon and Magnus he got a bit lucky
at times in the Armageddon but for him
it's now all about the classical games
he'll feel luck turns if he wins today
yes sir definitely and let's remind
ourselves of the standings and there is
one man at the top of the table Fabiano
caruano we're 13 and a half points out
of 18 but two and a half points behind
him is Hikaru Nakamura who will be
looking to win some more classical games
alireza farouza on third place and go
cash just 17 years old with eight and a
half points in fourth place and Magnus
Carlson while he's won the tournament
four times in a row these previous years
but it's looking like it might be an
uphill battle for him he languishes in
sixth place and well this leads us very
nicely to today's matchups at Norway
chess so every day is a winner for you
in terms of the actual chest fights we
see Magnus Carlson playing White against
Ali Reza farouza Wesley so nordbeck
abdusotoff so many fascinating
encounters which one Juda are you
eagerly anticipating well I'm very much
looking forward to this game of the
leader Fabiano versus gokash and also I
must say that
Nakamura game versus mamajaro will be
also something real excitement I think
because mama jaro will want to win
absolutely so many players who do want
to win and David what about you yes so
many storylines I also uh will be
watching Nakamura closely fighting not
just uh for first place in this
tournament but second place in the world
rankings and Anish giri playing his
former secondary antari so Mind Games
there that's for sure oh I can't wait
for this and it's part of what makes
Norway special is the field but it's
also the format which pushes chess
Beyond its boundaries because take a
look at this it's a 10 player single
round robin 120 minutes for the entire
game sounds like a lot really isn't and
a 10 second move sorry 10 second
increment added after move 40 and in the
case of a draw Armageddon will break the
tie no draw off and it's the scoring
system where if you win your classical
game you get three points and if you win
your Armageddon game only one and a half
points and this is what makes noise so
special and there we can see Abdul
satoroff he has the black pieces against
Wesley so oh taking a deep breath
perhaps some tension though
yeah he gave a death stare to the camera
for a second uh not to back he's had an
up and down tournament we've got to say
impressive uh at times he won the blitz
of course uh before the event but in
recent times as well some classical
defeats uh smiling there as his opponent
Wesley takes his seat
um yeah both players look in good
spirits I'm expecting this one to be uh
quite fiery if abdusitorov gets his way
he loves a full-blooded fight there uh
Wesley may be more solid throughout the
tournament so far now Anish and Arya
good friends we are in good mood as well
yeah
I mean it's an interest
to point it out there David the Anish
and Aryan has seconded Anish I mean what
do you think will be going through their
minds especially for a niche you know
because he he knows
what material he has revealed to Ariane
yeah that's the thing these two these
two will know everything uh there is to
know about each other especially in the
opening phase of the game of course they
get on extremely well Ariane was working
with a niche for uh the better part of a
year on and off so opening wise they've
had all the discussions it's just about
whether they kind of Follow The
Gentleman's Agreement where you don't
play anything you've discussed and try
to maybe Branch out find new territory
as early as possible or the mind games
where you just go something go down the
main line go down one of these lines
that you have analyzed together and hope
that you know more than your opponent
and uh here is a huge matchup tournament
leader Fabiana caruana with the white
pieces against gukesh I can remember a
game that they played against each other
in tata steel and their Fabiano actually
outwitted his young opponent he enticed
him to make some active decisions which
were badly timed do you think Fabiano
will do more of that same strategy or
will he kind of move on to a different
approach well I think Fabiano as he is
in a great form and he's extremely
stable in his play we could see that he
he has things under control somehow he
has a good mindset here in this
tournament he's incredibly stable
playing he's not making very risky
decisions but he's he's very practical
also at the same time and he sees that
he has a significant lead of course he
knows one thing that he cannot lose the
classical game that's very clear but I
think he will not go out with some crazy
stuff but he wants to play a normal game
as if it would be round one yeah and
there we see Magnus Carlsen and alireza
seated and I have to ask you both a
question
has Magnus lifted his chair up to its
highest
physical
dominance there to intimidate his
opponent he does look taller than normal
Magnus he's certainly does I mean I mean
Magnus is a tall guy but he definitely
does have an impressive stature on the
board maybe it's the hair gives him a
few extra inches with his height there
also alireza is very tall yeah but I
think when things are not going on your
own way and this is the tournament where
we can say for Magnus is the case you
try to change everything you change your
pen you change your hairstyle he took
off his shaved his beard you change the
set setting the height of your chair
you're changing your clothes you're
really trying everything
[Laughter]
yeah
actually you're right Ivanka alireza I
think he's about 190 in terms of height
and he looks tiny compared to Magnus
what's happened here
well the the players I've given a
handshake move has been made for Magnus
Magnus promptly taking it back
and the clock has been started and
Magnus opening with E4
this one will be such a fascinating
battle because as you actually mentioned
in the run-up
alireza farisa was someone that Magnus
has hand-picked as his successor for a
long time
yeah uh we all kind of think of Alaris
as a potential future world champion
that being said the last couple of years
it's been a bit mysterious he's played a
lot less and uh meanwhile the Sicilian
on the board yeah Alvarez he's played a
lot less maybe some inconsistent results
a bit up and down and yeah it's kind of
fascinating as well the head-to-head
that these two guys have I think we'll
talk about that a bit later but Magnus
definitely at least in classical chess
uh he's got a huge score against alireza
and uh okay what do we think of this
opening Choice a small surprise farrugia
playing the Sicilian Judith yeah I'm
very happy to see this position on the
board and I'm curious whether Magnus
will be going to the open Sicilian then
we are going to be seeing
housing which I played it was my line
for uh many years I had great successes
with that so I'm very curious if he's
going to the palsan or he wants to end
up in in the swashnikov because with
transposition we are able to get there
yeah and meanwhile Magnus I think will
not have expected this farucha it has
been a theme in the tournament that kind
of if given a choice he'll always press
the chaos button he'll always kind of
keep things interesting and take these
big risks which actually suits magnus's
tournament situation right now it suits
them both they both of course want to
win but interesting that Magnus
whoa that's not about slip I was going
to say interesting that Magnus pauses to
think but Bishop to D3 what is the
bishop doing there stuck between its own
pawns I've seen and done before I think
Lavon was uh trying this a few years ago
and the whole idea is to go C3 put the
bishop back on C2 and get a well-timed
D4 on the board but uh I do like these
Sidelines I was always a big fan of this
C3 control the center setups
well at first I would think that this is
for the Armageddon kind of preparation
Bishop D3 and I believe that it looks
much worse than it is because at first
it looks so unnatural
anti-chess kind of attitude to put the
bishop on D3 but it's completely true
what you said the Ivanka that after
white is going to be playing C3 Bishop
C2 D4 everything will be in order and
White's position
yeah so it's a clumsy looking move but
it's just temporarily clumsy here and it
will for sure Force farrugia to think uh
alarisa he has been a bit slow as well
he's been in many time scrambles uh he's
been in yeah under time pressure in most
of his games so maybe this is a ploy by
Magnus already as early as move three
getting the opponent thinking on his own
two feet you said it just changing
everything Magnus his whole opening
strategy as well and also of course for
Magnus he wants to get some interesting
game complications he knows exactly that
most probably he will not be the winner
of this tournament if things are going
the way it went for Fabiano and Nakamura
as well but still of course he would
want to have a great finish having three
out of three in the classical so at
least to show that he's the greatest and
number one and not
it's not for uh by chance
it's not in the past Bishop D3 wow here
I'm just expecting normal development by
black uh you can kind of play moves on
autopilot you can bring the Knight to C6
you can bring the other Knight out but
as you say you need a long-term plan to
fight white kind of getting reorganized
in the center the question is what about
in Black playing D5 immediately
question
D5 looks very natural
and Magnus has to either capture or
ignore it if that happens yes because if
white can can really regroup the bishop
to C2 like after let's say if we play
Knight C6 white can go C3 let's say
Knight D7 Castle G6 Bishop C2 Bishop G7
D4 I mean that we understand that
everything is fine right white just took
the bishop the route from D3 to C2 and
it didn't go as usually it does through
Bishop B5 Bishop A4 C3 Bishop C2 so
that's going to be just fine the
question is how black can punish white
for making such a awkward move like
Bishop D3 putting front of the Pawn on
D2
and your right D5 would have been an
attempt to punish uh White at least to
strike in the center and ask immediate
questions but El Ariza says no okay he
just develops now we're expecting Magnus
to go for one of those plans I'm not
sure which order you Castle first you
play C3 first
well the other idea also that maybe
Magnus does not want to play C3 after
all but he will be castling Rook E1 and
the bishop will come back to F1 that can
be also a strategy possibly yeah I've
also seen not in this type of position
but a B3 as well to get the bishop out
to B2 and then kind of combine that with
your castling and your rookie one ideas
oh well this one is certainly unorthodox
shall we take a look at the bird's eye
view and go back to
the boards
yeah and uh some very kind of far
advanced games despite the fact we've
only been uh in action for around five
minutes so far which games catch your
eye nakamura's game is uh already on
fire
I would
like to go to
game because I think that one looks like
a lot of fun just from one moment
because we'd actually have a clip of
Arya antari and Anish Gary actually
having fun
on these it's been uh
he's saying that it's an exciting game
against Anish he knows him very very
well yeah so
um
he actually they play together
Ariane played before that wasn't the it
was I thought they were having fun there
was an interview in Norwegian putting my
Norwegian language skills to the test
but incidentally one of my other
co-commodates is learning Norwegian
sound David
I am your Banker I understood about half
of that
he did say he knows him very well and
they have played together of course many
many times he seemed to be quite
optimistic about his chances Ariane and
of course he's had a tough tough
tournament but maybe just buoyed by the
fact that he managed to draw with Magnus
yesterday in the classical uh giving him
some confidence going into this one yeah
it's a Catalan what do we think Anish
has chances to press
early days still very theoretical should
we go and quickly recap this one from
move one we're now at move 10 in the
game let's see these two great friends
how they started the game it began with
1d4 Knight F6
and here we see the start of the Catalan
and black accepting the gift accepting
the Queen's Gambit almost and after C5
Queen to A4 one of the most theoretical
moves here is basically playing a
reverse grenfeld some serious ideas
along this diagonal if white can get the
movement Knight to E5 in the position so
this diagonal blocked Bishop to D7
the queen takes C4 B5 the queen Retreats
this a choice here you could step back
to D3 C3 and this position now on the
board and black has achieved a lot on
the queen side lots of Pawn advances
point to C4 however white now has an
unchallenged Pawn Center you could
imagine uh the pawn coming forward to E4
Rook to D1 and things exploding very
shortly and also with some ideas of
undermining Black's Pawn chain with A4
B3 so kind of pros and cons black skiing
space gain time against the White Queen
but
white also has a lot to be happy with
well I guess it's all Theory and it
seems like so far uh Anish Blitz it out
practically only two minutes went until
this point he's not sitting at his table
so he feels very comfortable probably
yeah
it's like a normal game but let's go
back to the bird's eye view and go to an
abnormal game but between Hikaru
Nakamura and Mama jarov because they're
the players have blitzed out 18 moves
and guys is this all like crazy Theory
I think so uh at least I was familiar
with the position up until two or three
moves ago uh wow this clash between the
two uh kind of fire Brands here Hikaru
and Shakura it's just exploded it looks
so Random if you show this position to
uh kind of grand Masters maybe 50 years
ago they'll be like what is this this is
just nonsense this is chaos but of
course it's computer approved and the
players have studied this very deeply
black has sacrificed a piece we're
talking about the material imbalance
just as we see it a set of knights have
left the board as well white king stuck
in the center and black has an attack
and a pawn for White Knight compensation
unit well big threat on the board Rook
D5 threatening to slide across with Rook
F5 pinning the White Queen
speed continues Queen to E4 we're at
move 22 and we've only been in action
for nine ten minutes this is crazy
but we see people on like move like less
than move tan and then these guys are on
move 22 and wow it's seems like both
sides have a home cooked their
preparation yeah just for context Magnus
Carlson against alireza farouza is on
move four right now and this game is on
move 22 black to play well probably
shortly we're going to get some
information from from Hikaru in the
confessional Booth hopefully explaining
until which point was it home
preparation for him he's uh he's not
quite no I think he's observing the
other games now
okay okay yeah yeah of course of course
our man on the ground has to look at
everyone else's games and give us his
thoughts yeah and while both players are
away from the board I think we should
catch up just show how we got to this
wild position it was a very theoretical
opening one of the most topical openings
out there these days oh wow big move
played by alireza faroogia my eyes being
caught there we'll go back to that one
shortly but uh this game Nakamura
started with D4 he knows that mamajarov
has been doubling in the Queen's Gambit
accepted for a long time so Hikaru could
predict that E4 E5 would appear on the
board this has been a big discussion a
big debate so far in Norwich s E5 Abdul
satorov also playing this opening
recently uh this was met by Knight of
three a check Knight C3 the block and
now rather than the end game approach he
takes D4 just trying to equalize trying
to kind of vacuum pieces off the board
we saw Knight F6 Knight takes E5 and B5
we also saw this earlier in the
tournament uh I think that was alireza
against
Majora perhaps and uh yeah that one was
equally chaotic and my major of crashing
to defeat despite having a good position
after castles A4 met fire with fire here
C5 counter-attack hitting the White
Center while the white king is in the in
the middle still Bishop E3 uh trade of
Pawns and queen to E7 uh I've looked at
this position before and this is all
kind of top engine suggestion of course
as you expect with uh modern chess black
here threatening to actually trap the
White Queen in the center so white gives
the queen an escape square a takes B5
now we can escape via C4 and of course
black gives up a second Pawn hits the
White Queen gains a lot of time
double attack now and we see a P
sacrifice in a moment from black after
Knight back to C4 Knight D7 Rook to A6
beautiful move sliding across to C6 and
this is where things get really spicy I
must admit until this point I was
familiar Rook to A6 uh less so Knight C5
Rook C6 double attack hitting the queen
at night and after Queen F2 boom Knight
takes E4 black has to be quick black has
to justify the two Pawn deficit somehow
sacrificing an extra piece throwing more
fuel on the fire and after Knight takes
E4 we see
let's just catch up with the game a
check King F2 Rook D5 threatening this
pin and queen to E4 the most recent move
on the board well it seems Seems like
that the chakria uh was prepared of
course but after Queen E4 maybe he is
out of book yeah maybe looking one move
deeper
and depth of preparation here uh is all
important of course
I should mention Nakamura once prepared
42 moves against me uh in the game we
got to move 42 and he had two hours or
three hours even on his clock because he
gained an extra hour and I sat there
with 30 seconds left trying to survive
and I made a draw somehow by a miracle
but it's scary when Hikaru gets his
preparation in 42 moves yeah and he said
it was a draw I held a fortress and he
was like oh the computer said plus three
though so
Hikari knows everything wow very
researcher there what do we make of this
position
I I don't know I'm trying to fetch off
with with the things what's going on it
seems like white has an extra piece and
The Rook F5 seems to be the most obvious
at first but with the white king wants
to sneak out to G1 right
castling by hand almost although the
white rook in the corner I guess would
be stuck if white does play King G1 so
some long-term compensation Maybe
but black must be needing something over
the next few moves the stakes are so
high peace down well for the moment we
can say that how are the pieces are
standing right this is the only thing I
can start with
while we get our bearings yeah I mean
white has a vulnerable King
Queen on e4 I think stands fantastic in
the center Rook on C6 extremely active
very stable with the pawn on B5 Knight
on C4 exceptionally well plays because
it covers some important squares like
the E5 Square so Rook E5 is not possible
at all and the white is ready in the
next move if let's say it would be white
to move white would definitely play
developing move like Bishop E2 and
Bishop F3 and the game is over so this
is a momentum very clearly that black
has to show how to show the compensation
right so this is my Rooker 5 or queen F6
also makes a lot of sense to push the
king back to G1 which makes the H1 Rook
um
it's not very active for the moment it's
sleeping yeah the words are tall
but it's also very difficult to spot a
Target in White's position because the
black has a lot of loose pieces that
they have to take care of so for
instance if you do threaten if you do
play Rook at five and King to G1 then
there are some big threats of Rook text
Bishop on the board
well I think the problem is that maybe
maybe there is one only move which is
still keeping the compensation so there
must be only moves in this position for
the next five or seven or eight moves
and of course black can go wrong much
easier than white because black has to
prove it that he has the compensation so
what I'm thinking that maybe Rook 88
after giving a check because of course I
don't want Bishop e to be to to be
played by white so what about playing
Rook F5 checking G1 and then rook d8 and
I want to come Rook to D1 yeah let's put
this on the board so you want to give a
check uh very natural move and King G1
pretty much forced and Rook d8 you want
to come in
and this is scary so if I play Bishop E2
to cover this Square I'm scared I'm
going to get checkmated on the back rank
somehow but well that's heavy evaluation
very nice drives like Bishop C4 yeah
beautiful
setting you up here if I take the black
queen now oh free Queen until oh I
blundered oh no I rugby one if you took
that I I give up another one yeah but
the the funny thing is I just wanted to
show it how funny line is but actually I
think it black is doing good Bishop C4
because after Rook C4 Rook E5
oh nice uh yeah so this is a beautiful
Checkmate here but even if white kind of
avoids the strap rotate C4 you skewer me
actually so many Targets on the e-file
now
um You regain them peace with uh with
interest
yeah winning attack here black simply
playing a rook up actually we talked
about this H1 Rook
yeah but there are it's such a wild
position so there's a lot of dangers for
both sides so we have to be super
concrete as well but one second I don't
is for the moment if we go back to the
starting position after Rook F5 King G1
Bishop C4 would be the same idea already
which is working but poor black after
Rook C4 Rook E5 the A8 Rook is hanging
so this is why it does not work for the
moment
that's why you need to move this Rook
improve this rook and this is so
interesting nowadays in chess I think
that you see a position and you cannot
have a judgment by intuition because if
that Rook would be on B8 maybe black is
just doing fine with Rook C5 but we have
Queen F6 on the board yeah the queen of
six was the alternative check which I
was thinking about as well
and still the same ideas are are in play
the King has to hide itself on G1
yeah and it will be interesting the pace
with which this game continues King G1 I
think mabajarov he paused there just for
a few minutes recollecting his thoughts
uh it shows that he's still in
preparation as well I feared for him if
uh Shakura hadn't gone deep enough if
he'd kind of looked up to this point but
hadn't kind of figured out how to
justify the peace sacrifice then we
might have seen a very quick Hikaru win
but nice that's uh mamajarov and kind of
reaffirming that he played Queen F6
quickly and now he needs another move to
back it up yeah because there is a
threat right of Queen takes Rook on the
board for white
ooh Queen takes rook and this would be a
simplifying tactic because the black
queen would drop if black recaptures on
D5 yeah nice spot there will black
player of the eight or he has something
more Concrete in mind for example Rook
D1 will be mad by Queen F3 I believe
following the Golden Rule right your
trade of Queens when your king is in
danger but um so
okay so we we should try these things up
because here it really is just the most
forcing moves on the board
so what do we say Rook D1 or Rook 88
introduce another piece
Let's uh show these yeah as you say
Ivanka the most direct move Rook D1
threatens Checkmate of course in one
move but after Judith's queen of three
how do we keep the flame alive how do we
keep fighting here Rogue d8 is on the
board oh yeah this one there's no rush
you know
who
needs
there's an expression as an
italian-based expressions like make
haste but don't hurry
okay so Rook D1 now may be threatened
it feels like white at some point needs
to give the king some breathing space I
really I don't know why I'm I was about
to say I'm going to push my Pawn to H4
but Hikaru beats me to it Bishop takes
A7 it's time to grab bones at Tempo
though and you didn't say this what
happened to you
I didn't have the chance to digest what
was happening Judith I mean the courage
is playing so quickly no this was the
first time in life where you were scared
to take that bone
it's official Hikaru is a porn Grabber
Shameless Bishop takes A7 wow and maybe
he thinks that there's just no rush uh
I'm sure he studied this with an engine
otherwise you don't have the courage to
kind of weaken this diagonal uh near
your king but it's still holding
together Hikaru he's can still swoop
back with the queen to F3 if necessary
but what is self-confidence you have to
have to Blitz this out I mean he could
even spend some time just to make sure
if if everything is okay but he has this
self-confidence I know what I'm doing
I'm going to grab this spawn I'm doing
fine
or the other way around he wants to give
the impression that he knows everything
and not everything is under control even
if it's okay for black I think we can
safely assume two things are gonna
happen in this game either one side is
gonna forget what they uh should be
doing and lose very quickly or we'll see
some more fire on the board and things
just level out towards a draw a force
draw because the evaluation bar is still
in Center despite White having an extra
night meaning black should have
sufficient resources
wow dramatic stuff I think it will be a
draw in the end that's that's my guess
because many of these very sharp
tactical things end up in a draw
breaking news
Hikaru has just given us a confessional
so take it away Hikaru
welcome back everyone so in my typical
YouTube fashion I'll try to say welcome
back and it's probably going to be a
very short day unfortunately
um
so I wasn't really sure what chakra
would play in the opening he's played
the Queen's Gambit accepted from both
the white side and the blacks and his
attorney had the similar similar
position against all her as a frugia
very early on you also played this
against Wesley so yesterday with the
white pieces now I wasn't sure if he
would do this um basically I didn't
really find anything super exciting here
or elsewhere in E4 or C4 so I thought I
would just play and hope hope for the
best um as it turns out basically when I
looked this for the game this night the
sacrifice of the night on e4 is the best
line with any other move
um white white is definitely a little
bit better but after this Knight he
takes E4 this is all pretty standard I
mean there's probably going to be a
force repetition coming up a shocker our
nose nose line out of course it's never
been played before so you sort of have
to just take your chances and hope and
it seems like unfortunately shocker
actually did his homework and I think my
game is going to be a draw probably
within the next 10 minutes
um you know it's modern day chess I
guess simply simply put up one games
where I sort of played the memory test
before very famously on circuit cardiac
and in Zurich many years ago we played
this English opening and it was all prep
all memorization surrogate was not able
to remember the correct lines over the
board and I won that game very nicely
here unfortunately looks like shocker
does know what he's doing so barring
something insane happening like unless
shocker or something goes deep into the
tank here most likely this game is going
to be drawn pretty soon there are a
couple ways for black to play here but
the most common one is between F16 G1
Rook 88 Bishop A7 Rook F5 Bishop B3 work
back to rook fd5 and computer just says
it's complete zero so we'll see if he
knows it I'm not very optimistic about
it but you know if your opponent knows
every single move out to move 30 they
notice after piece and that's just life
what to do so a little bit disappointing
but that's how it goes
oh and Hikaru telling us that he is
playing the memory game and also telling
us that he once did defeat sir Sergey
karakin in that game but he also
mentioned the repetition
so David can you show us what Hikaru was
uh talking about yeah we have to see
whether Hikaru will be on point with his
prediction here he uh basically went
down this variation and in this position
he is predicting Rook to F5 let's show
this on the board because this is not
obvious if Mama jarov hasn't studied
this exact position hasn't done his
homework and fails the memory test Rook
to F5 of course hitting this bishop on
F1 Hikaru said he intends to play the
move Bishop to D3 uh very logical move
looks like you're pinning along this
diagonal but actually back to D5 is the
key move here just not seeing any ghosts
hitting this white bishop and White's
here I think Hikaru intends to just drop
back and repeat the position because if
you do get greedy and take on H7 then
the black king simply runs it's going to
run safely towards the center and
actually it's the white king that might
well get checkmated for example you
cannot give a check from this angle
because black simply removes the bishop
and next move delivers Checkmate so yeah
Rook F5 and a bit of a yoyo here five
Bishop D3 Rook D5 and this is the
predicted draw from Hikaru well I think
it's nice to show that after Rook F5
Bishop E2 is not an option for white
because white can guard both important
squares D1 and F1 so Rook D1 would be
making two moves
and there is one other option for white
to deal with the the move Knight The
Rook F5 and in some way to protect the
F1 Bishop right so Queen E2 seems to be
very scary for white because it's very
passive but what would be the move after
that
um
it feels like there's going to be some
thing on the tactics right feels like
there's something in the air at the
moment Bishop D4 at least you can meet
with a capture and a block maybe this is
still good for black uh you can block
with the Knights or the queen on E3 well
if you play Queen E3 then Bishop C4 yeah
exactly the same trick
should take C4 removing the defend of
the White Queen and then Checkmate next
move this pattern keeps recurring and
yeah if Knight to E3 it feels like there
should be a knockout here maybe E5 yeah
E5 pin along this diagonal and this file
and most likely F2
yeah
where's the Killer
you need a one last punch to get to this
King
well Bishop g54
before yeah overwhelmed the white
defenses evaluation of our less
convinced but still very scary I don't
think Hikaru would risk this well
interesting we will uh keep you all
updated whether Shaq does find The Rook
F5 and then the Rook D5 repetition that
he mentioned there but in the meantime
let's head back to the bird's eye view
because we have many other wonderful
games in Play and uh shall we check out
tournament leader Fabiana Carolina
against 17 year old good cash
yeah let's go there this game also has
seen many many moves and okay it's a
slower different type of position dude
this one's more of a maneuvering battle
it came from an anti-birlin which we've
seen multiple times this tournament
white parting with the bishop pair but
black has a slightly damaged structure
with doubled C pawns so Carolina taking
a slow approach what do we think of this
current position
I don't know exactly what what black is
going to be doing of course the question
is whether is he want to give up the
file by playing 8xb4 which is not
something you want to give up so easily
especially if you have an alternative
and an option to keep the tension
so
so for now maybe with black uh but it's
interesting that having H6 on the board
F6 doesn't seem to be such a tempting
move it's not that it gives such a huge
weaknesses on G6 or White can exploit it
but still I mean usually I like to play
F6 in such a position defend the E5 then
move the Rook maybe move the Knight away
yeah it's uh yeah it's hard to find a
plan as you mentioned or at least a
productive move that you're kind of
happy with that improves your position I
should mention that maybe the most
famous game between these two was from
last year's olympiadica cash one a
really nice game and a tactical Wild
game with black and it does feel like
ever since that moment Carolina has so
much respect for him that he just wants
to slow the game down yeah but we
shouldn't forget this Fabiano had an
awful Olympian it was an awful form and
here go cash had an incredible form
showing I think seven seven out of seven
that was his start and then he slowed
down
by beating carono right yes but maybe
White's plan is to go Knight C4 quickly
if let's say black is not doing anything
special then Knight C4 would be coming
and if you don't play F6 and after
Knight C4 you have to capture that so
let's say if you're looking to move
rookie 8.
say let's jump in and show this is
Knight C4 a threat that's the big
question Rook E8 yeah if I can go Knight
C4
and let's say black has to take on C4
they take C4 and of course black does
not want to play C5 to block the bishop
completely
and C5 would be a threat because this
would be a huge Advantage for white
yeah we've seen this from actually
orientaree's games where he's
inadvertently locked in his bishop and
well it looked better it's right it
looked better than this one but still it
was bad enough
and we have ethics B4 on the board so
there was a capture
yeah and a quick recapture from Carolina
and so this is the other theme you were
mentioning Judo now the a file has
opened
um actually this question persists
Knight C4 it might well be kind of a
theme over the next few moves and black
needs an answer to that one but let's
say black plays F6 and then after Knight
C4 black does not have to capture on C4
but he can move back with the queen to
E7
and I don't think Knight B6 can be so
dangerous for black
capturing the bishop it's possible I
think I would be taking back with the
pawn but I'm not sure it's good but for
a moment D4 is not possible uh I mean it
is possible but Bishop C4 can be strong
also later on black can go B5 and Knight
B6 to C4
yeah looks like black is solid enough
opposite color Bishops and unless things
really open up but also after D4 Bishop
G4 is possible that's also something to
consider I believe
yes this is the most forcing line but it
looks like also what gocast should do I
totally agree uh kind of I want to play
F6 here even if kind of blacks played
this one
whoa Bishop D4
okay active
I was actually going to say this uh
gukash is a very active Dynamic always
up for a fight kind of player
and that's how Fabiano used
um his psychology just to beat him in
their game in tata steel so I wondered
whether like a dry technical position
like this is actually something that
kakesh is not necessarily that uh
comfortable with
yeah I've played good cash twice in my
career and both times I just try to make
it dry and dull and both times he kind
of uh got a bit over excited and lashed
out and it backfired a bit later on so I
I totally understand Fabiano's
um kind of strategy here but gokesh
unfortunately against the best place
they always seem to get that type of
position and uh go cash their Bishop D4
the more I look at it the more I like it
read it yes actually it crossed my
first fraction of a second Bishop D4 but
then I said no no it's gonna be the move
but uh actually it is very interesting
because white cannot take with the night
because he would be losing a pawn right
he takes D4 and after the white Bishop
has to move away and then simply Queen
B4 so this means that white has to react
in a different way but it's not so easy
for white how to do so because let's say
if he captures it with the bishop then
he takes D4 and the E6 Bishop covers the
B3 so white cannot jump simply Knight B3
to attack the D4 pawn and I don't see
for the moment how white will pose real
problems or dangers to the D4 Pawn if we
exchange
yeah let's show this on the board a
really nice move here from good cash
counterintuitive I would say
um wow breaking news we did have that
draw between Hikaru and Nakamura and
Shakura mamajarov so we will see a first
Armageddon of the day but uh yeah just
to show this point Queen takes B4 huge
threat it's got intuitive because you
give up the bishop pair you kind of
ruined the black pawn structure even
further but there's a clear weakness at
Clear targets and like drew that says
this bishop kills this white Knights and
the B4 Pawn is the weakness right for
now it's not easy to protect it of
course white can go Queen B1 so for the
moment it's protected but for white it
would be very nice somehow to play F4
but it's not going to be easy though
after this white can be okay it can be
once threatening with Queen B2 if black
captures on A1 Queen A1 Queen B4 and I
think Rook B1
hitting this Pawn also if you need to
you can take this Pawn off the board but
after that Queen C3 might be strong
three yeah
maybe in this position instead of Queen
uh instead of Rook B1 I mean it depends
on the evaluation of this type of
position well Queen D4 of course
and white has more Central pawns which
can be quite comfortable
but uh black is very active especially
you know say for instance you were to
trade Queens
I'm not sure whether that's the best
move but I'm just kind of highlighting
that The Rook can come to A8 and be a
nuisance
yeah start coming in maybe dynamically
balanced this uh this type of end game
but maybe white can go F4 finally
push their spawns and I guess the Black
Knight moves to create squares for the
bishop to escape to before you start
hitting me trapping this piece
and Bishop D4 is on the board so we're
going to get something similar to this I
believe yeah
and of course it will be it will come as
a big relief to Fabiano that Hikaru
actually drew his classical game
so if he like takes it to Armageddon
with a draw then it's not such a big
deal he will still maintain his two and
a half point lead or at least yeah at
least or two a two-point lead uh yeah
Fabiano so yeah it feels like a safety
net here for him he'll of course have
one eye on the other results uh for
Hikaru with the white pieces he said it
in the confessional right he was a bit
disappointed but it's a decent kind of
trustworthy strategy these days to test
the opponent but sometimes if the
opponents have done enough homework uh
in the opening you do end up with these
quick draws
and there we can see the bird's eye view
and already just looking at the bird's
eye view I can see some surprising moves
by alireza I mean what is that porn
doing on G5
question I think bit transposed
to some position because
but how is it possible that it's I
suppose should we go and update
ourselves in this game between Carlson
and farrugia it's only been a couple
more moves but uh very surprising
unexpected moves something very funny
going on there
funny for who that's the question well
it's the only thing that black has an
extra tempo right yeah so uh let's
backtrack this is the current position
we were lost at this game here after
White had castled and black lashed out
faruga we've said it before anytime you
give him an opportunity even if it's a
kind of weird looking opportunity he
will go for the active move in the
position and G5 taking advantage of the
fact that white cannot open the center
yet he wants to fight on the king side
at least gain some space there gain some
10 piece against this uh White Knight G4
incoming Bishop B5 now yeah can I tell
you that someone has actually thought of
the move G5 before it was a game uh it
was the Moscow rapid between two strong
growing and passes David
paravian and Boris gretchev okay and
David paravian out of QRC was white he
was white yeah did he play Bishop B5 as
well no that was C3 was the reaction
then okay and a white loss but it was a
rapid game so yep C3 and I guess the
white Knights kicked back and black
gains a lot of space on the king side
that's interesting to me because uh
paravian works very closely with Daniel
duboff who is the second of Magnus
Carlson so it's maybe some uh idea
sharing there by osmosis just uh yeah
sharing is caring as they say and top
players know all of the top ideas these
days I'm sorry you made me laugh so much
then with sharing is caring because that
is literally the motto of my nieces
they're like they're under five and you
hear that that phrase all the time
yeah and the top players do share ideas
from time to time you've got to be
careful who you share them with though
lots of kind of cloak and daggers it's
like a spy novel sometimes the top
players in their seconds but Bishop B5
okay moving the bishop for a second time
Judith do you like this move
um
I don't know what's the idea behind it
but well actually it has a straight idea
to play D4 right that's the that's the
key point and also at some point he
wants to eliminate the knight from C6
uh but what Magnus is saying is that I
can afford to have one Tempe down just
because you play G5 and the question is
whether is it correct because of course
tempies does count in this position
because if it would be right to move of
course you go D4 or somehow some active
move at the same time black played the
bishop G7 and as we see firoza to play
these kind of moves does not need too
much of provocation
true so Magnus I think he's kind of got
what he wants he just kind of he's got a
fresh position where opening Theory
doesn't play a part but at the same time
for roof has got what he wants he's got
an active plan here G4 might come at the
right moment kicking back the White
Knight what moves come to mind here I'm
looking again at C3 uh I'm not sure you
can get away with any breaks in the
center now of course you want to make D4
work opening up the bishop against this
Pawn but D4 the big question is do you
have enough compensation after G4 the
answer might not be uh positive here for
Magnus so really turn after this last
move after this last kind of sequence
oh very tense start very creative start
from both players I have to say and I
think it's the perfect time to take a
break
there will be an Armageddon game
happening in 15 minutes but for now
let's mention the junior speed Chess
Championship the 2023 speed chess season
begins with the junior speed Chess
Championship on June the 13th this four
day event showcases the best young
talent in speed chess with over 45
000 on the line but the real prize goes
to the top finisher alone who moves on
to the main speed Chess Championship
later this summer catch all the action
starting June the 13th right here at
twitch.tv forward slash chess use x-clam
jscc in chat for all the details and
we'll be right back after the break
[Music]
thank you
what's the best way to follow any chess
event from the Champions chess tour to
the candidates speed chess championship
title Tuesday feed a world championship
and so much more chess.com events has
all of the top chess tournaments played
both over the board and online
analyze and review games from the
world's greatest players with live
commentary cloud analysis opening
Explorer and table bases find all the
key event information including
schedules prizes results news reports
player bios tie breaks and more
even compete by voting for your
predicted results
explorechess.com events today on web or
with our IOS and Android apps and
experience chess like never before
[Music]
different possible positions after two
moves nine million different possible
positions after three moves
318 billion different possible positions
after four moves I'm gonna play the
London seriously I'm sorry
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
hello and welcome back and I'm your host
International Master Ivanka houska and
some breaking news we've actually just
had Magnus Carlson in the confessional
Booth sharing with us his opening
thoughts so let's go there and have a
listen
that's true the through the other time
uh the thing is
um
so uh foreign
[Music]
so
that is
so Magnus revealing that he didn't know
anything this is him just freestyling
and winging it are we surprised
I I love the expression he was giving
apart from revealing the secret kind of
thing I mean he was just laughing on the
whole situation that he's playing here
in Norway chance he was probably
spending hours of preparation and move
three it's out of book which is not very
often that you can have a game from move
three and hold your head in your hands
you know what he reminded me of that in
the interview it was a naughty Schoolboy
who hasn't done his homework
he kind of he knew Bishop D3 was a move
he's just whoops I forgot to do the
homework on it but of course he can make
it work he's strong enough and I think
it has the benefit of throwing alireza
uh on his own as well
and one move has been played there
Bishop takes C6 uh Bishop for nitrate
this one yeah anything could still
happen of course but uh Magnus will be
trying to work things in his favor
definitely and uh now the pawn structure
has relatively become familiar except
this inclusion of G5 is there anything
that Magnus or alireza will be thinking
about
that will help them
guide their pieces to the correct
squares well G5 of course is not very
common to stand exactly at the same time
you know that I'm a big fan of G5 and G4
moves so I can imagine very well that
the black can push G4 and H5 and develop
not necessarily castling at all and it
can be an interesting idea or make it
work to be interesting but with alireza
also that he always has a very creative
interesting ideas
and
this is what we're witnessing now and uh
well we are like 50 minutes into play
and we already have our first Armageddon
between Hikaru Nakamura and Shakura
mamajarov
and there is everything to play for here
white will have 10 minutes on
10 minutes on the clock yeah so sorry I
was I was on the phone just saying 10
seconds and I was like no you can't say
10 seconds 10 minutes on the clock and
black will have seven minutes and this
is the most important thing that white
will have to win black gets the draw
odds and the players are given a one
second piece of Hope because they get
some increment after move 40 and there
we see Hikaru in a must-win situation he
can't obviously repeat the same line
that he played in the classical game
against Shaq and there you go handshake
and they are off and Hikaru playing the
ready opening and following up with B3
yeah this is his tried and tested Blitz
repertoire he does this pretty much
consistently online uh therefore no big
surprise for Mama jorov and a quick
start to this game black occupying the
Center White playing this kind of hybrid
between the reti and well Bishop takes
F6 wrecking the black pawn structure at
the cost of the bishop parachute it I
find it very interesting and brave to go
to this kind of system go for the very
slow Play Because giving up the bishop
pair is also something that you might be
hesitant right but probably he knows
what he's doing he wants to develop his
pieces he knows that chakra is a player
who makes uh the position complicated so
it's not that he wants to be so solid
but it seems like Hikaru wants to have
something incredibly solid game and then
play it out and maybe playing for the
time element of our market and he's
really utilizing the idea that when
you're fighting against the bishop pair
you should set up your pawns on the same
color complexion on the bishop that you
don't have so there you go they're all
on dark squares but how is hikara
actually going to win this because he
has to make a break at some point in the
game he will have to make a break and he
first has to maneuver his Knights to
better squares black is Rock Solid here
of course maybe the one big Target long
term is the D5 Pawn this Pawn is fixed
in the center if White's Knights ever
land up on better squares okay nice
Retreat there Knight E1 showing the
point Knight D3 Knight F4 uh then this
Pawn could eventually become a long-term
Target so
I don't know I I have analyzed these
types of positions actually I think I've
looked at the exact position artificial
takes F6 myself with computers are not
impressed but Hikaru knows the
exceptions he knows which positions are
easy to play and he has fast vast
experience from all of his Blitz Games
online in this type of uh structure
that's why he's able to move so quickly
and
we can see it already manager of maybe
less comfortable he has played quite
slowly uh up to this point
he has indeed only five and a half
minutes on the clock and Mary jar of
developing the light squared Bishop a
great move but already after Knight F4
he will have to make a decision probably
he wants to go Bishop E4 centralizing
the bishop with the provoking Nakamura
but it's not so easy for white to play
F3 because then the bishop takes the
Knight and the E3 Pawn will be
vulnerable so after Bishop F4 what is he
up to
wow creative Bishop H3 normally you want
to get rid of the bishop pair here but
Black's Bishop maybe a bit of a target
for White's pieces whereas the white
Bishop is needed to hit that D5 Pawn
later well it's definitely an idea which
comes well when you play an Armageddon
game and you want to surprise your
opponent so the idea is that one time F3
will come but probably before that white
will develop his Knight to D2 at the
same time there is a good chance that
Bishop F4 is the plan of mamajarov and
uh Hikaru retreating his Knight to E2
his idea being I guess that if the
bishop does land on F3 it can be chased
Away by then oh and it's there already
and here I was expecting Hikaru to
develop the Knight to D2 and Chase it
away but then there is some tactical
idea Bishop can capture the Knight takes
and then C takes D4 taking the Central
Pawn and there is a pin so black would
be taking an extra Pawn there
okay and if the natural move isn't
possible then already
white will might even have to look at
moves like Bishop to G2 okay he
reinforces the defense of E2
but what is hikara doing with his Queen
side pieces and there we say see a trade
of Pawns in the middle of the board
yeah I think Hikaru will admit himself
that these objectively aren't the best
moves for white but he's just asking big
questions of mamajarov and if you look
at the clock times it's a four minute
time Advantage now ah look at that but
Queen D3 I was wondering
so wow double exclamation mark there
Queen D3 Bishop D4 yeah if the White
Queen moves then Bishop takes D4 and
there's a pin on the e-file double
exclamation mark means it's a brilliant
unexpected move and it is a sacrifice if
this bishop is captured the black queen
okay we're gonna see this on the board
she swoops in and look at the white king
is it going to survive really on F1 win
H6
beautiful geometry there Judith Queen
back to H6 is one of the best of course
maybe rookie eight is the the best move
because there's so much pressure on the
E5 he got a carry on building and well
hikara desperately needs to get those
extra pieces into the game
well Mama door office
in the game yeah
yeah it's like Hikaru raised the red
right flag to the bull here and Knight
takes D4 is our incoming so I mean can
you can white play Knight C3 and get
away with everything oh Hikaru
he's in desperation mode
I'm a driver leans back to check how
many moves they have played he will get
increment in 21 moves time uh he cannot
think of that though he's got four
minutes and he needs to deliver
Checkmate to justify this peace
sacrifice but it looks good it looks
promising for black
a giraffe in the attack against one of
the best defenders in the world Hikaru
Nakamura
probably after Knight D4 he wants to
take on D4
giving up for the White Queen
in some lines perhaps this one's getting
sharp Knight D2 trying to eliminate
Black's Bishop but white cannot actually
play a knight takes Bishop at all
because the Knight on E2 will fall and
oh Shaq has spotted something and he
takes the Knight off the board
okay white is going to end up totally
strung up here just totally paralyzed
after Rook takes Bishop maybe just Queen
to D3 what about Queen the exhibition I
was wondering whether you could actually
use your idea of playing Queen H6
but maybe yeah Queen H6 is actually but
then right uh yeah if White Queen takes
the Rook takes takes King G7 and double
attack the X and it's happening it's on
the board what's he gonna do oh Shaq
what a move and when G2 will be possible
to play I didn't see that one yeah I
yeah I'm not so sure about this okay
Shaq now has got a third Pawn however
for his piece the white King's still
weak
yeah
yeah giving the opportunity for Naka to
take the two Rooks for the White Queen
Nakamura said no and what do you think
is white just too uh tied up here to
hope for an advantage well Mama Jared
plays brilliantly I think absolutely on
a higher level than most of the
Armageddon games we can say because it
was a beautiful sacrifice and he's keep
playing the best moves I believe also
later on maybe F5 is something to
consider completely
uh take out the Bishop's power on H3 and
for white it's very difficult to make a
move because now if King goes for
example to G1 then Queen D2 there is
some tactics and black just wants to
play Knight C2 for example in the next
move huge threat you're right Judith
Knight C2 knife jumps in yeah all the
forks in the world and not easy here for
Hikaru to guard against those you can
see finally he slowed down eating up his
time trying to find any uh defensive
resource not easy Knight C2 a killer
threat
the shark is down to 346 in time but I
think looking his body language he feels
extremely comfortable right oh and uh
Hikaru moving his Bishop to G4 but that
doesn't deal with the threat of Knight
C2 does it
it doesn't deal with Knight C2 it also
asks the question what if F5 if black
just pushes a pawn to hit this bishop
but Shaq does of course jump in and
Nakamura okay giving up material trying
to consolidate but black has too much
bones black has three pawns and a rook
for the two pieces and uh what would be
your pick to leave a set of Rooks on the
board or to take everything off and
shark says you know what I don't care I
will let white have that Rook on the
board well I should not exchange queens
now
oh and just as you say it or in a better
circumstances right but I would probably
move away with the queen to day three
and after that Rook C8 but you see the
computer doesn't like the Rook C8 move
question mark given to that move uh Mama
George does have draw odds and he still
has the advantage so maybe in the grand
scheme of things trading the Queens was
fine but objectively with White's King
being so weak keeping the Queen's on
would have made a lot of logical sense
there uh so Nakamura can he work his
endgame magic the current material
balance is White having a knight and
Bishop for blacks rook and three Pawns
feels like too many bones there but uh
manager needs to find some active moves
before White's pieces coordinate well if
he stays
[Music]
stays interesting enough to Rook a to C3
King D4 marching ahead that can be an
okay E3 on the board the board and I was
wondering here whether black can
actually step forward with the d-pawn
and give a check to the king
that I like but white is going to be
playing King D3 and maybe black will
play somehow give up that pawn on
purpose and possibly playing Rook check
when the king takes the opponent then
The Rook for example goes back but now I
think it's critical moment how shark
will uh play but exactly he's going to
be going on your way yeah but the more I
looked at it the more I didn't really
like it
because the pawn on D4 is a Target in
the long run and the White Knight now
can jump to the C4 square and that's why
you see Shaq give a check but the king
can step up the board and grab the pawn
White's King leading from the front here
but at least he has one opponent if he
can somehow coordinate again maybe move
his Knight forward or there's going to
be checks Hikaru is giving a great fight
after having a very difficult opening
and the blunder but uh chat reminding us
all that a draw isn't good enough for
Hikaru but that's the thing my major off
is perhaps thinking too much of the draw
he had winning opportunities he could
have kept the Queens on gone for
checkmate
at least momentum is on white side
whether objectively a win is possible
that's another question
but it's all about momentum in these
Armageddon games two minutes only for
Shaq here
I mean it's going to be time Scramble
for the rest of time in this game
okay first
rotating his Knight as he would say
Nakamura retreating his Knight back to
F1 covering his kingside pawns and
Bishop to D5 very interesting decision I
must say but Rook E2 would be very good
I think
big threat there maybe introduce it
Flex pawns coming how is white going to
escape from this pin the self-imposed
pin that he's put on his Bishop well
hikar is untangling he's lined up his
Rook to Aid the bishop and his defense
and uh Hikaru just putting his pieces in
safe squares oh some hesitation from
Shaq
he's in Hikaru when these types of
positions so many times it never starts
off well but the longer he survives the
greater his chances will become another
white king is ready to escape from some
pins
well probably Rook D3 will be on the
board just defending it ah look at that
all the pieces cuddling up huddling up
together in the center
black will have to play King F6
and probably he will be going back and
forth look at this white king might
start infiltrating on the queen side I
don't know it feels like Sharky's just
playing moves as quickly he wants to
play F4 now to exchange so that was a I
think a very good move probably should
have been played one move earlier
for the first time in a while Shaq has a
plan to trade off all the kingside pawns
probably white will be going Rook D4
stopping this move F4 black attacks the
Knight
uh-huh predicting everything here Judith
another white knight black squares a bit
of a dilemma for Nakamura again a draw
not enough otherwise he would simply
step back with his Rook okay second time
repetition
oh he cannot repeat any longer Nakamura
he needs a new idea
and the players have now passed move 40
and that means they will be getting that
one second increment per move
well for Nakamura it's very difficult to
defend against F4 I think he will be
going back to D4 with the rook and after
rookie to King D3 no it changes
with the Knight
you are regrouping the problem is
White's King side pawns are so weak so
vulnerable and white is a bit stuck in
the center at the moment so at the same
time mamajaro seems to be confused yeah
shark just needs to move
one minute now
he gives a check forcing the white king
to make a decision has to step back
surely
going too far forward I think you'll get
punished and okay quick instant reply by
mama jarov
he's going for those white king side
pawns but now the white king is running
to their protection Bossa playing with
the phone in their hands
they're quite nervous what's going on
I can't blame them I would be nervous as
well right now Rook check abajarov needs
this point if he wants to fight for the
lead in the tournament King F4 oh he's
running into the lions den here
but manager of just Retreats goes back
well there is a blunder opportunity for
Nakamura with Knight E3 then Rook F2
check and F6 mate yeah and uh Shack now
under the minute and Hikaru with some
decisions to make while he pushes his a
pawn forward
but you see the evaluation bar go in
Black's favor
what is wrong with this porn I think
Rook H1
maybe there were some tricks there using
the pin on the white Bishop but instead
manager of just yo-yoing with his black
Rook on the second rank just causing
threats annoying uh Nakamura here okay
but hesitation once more he's under the
one minute Mark he's under the 30 second
Mark even Rook to E1
and Nakamura is surely going to improve
his Knights it looks like somehow some
small kind of missed opportunities and
the longer white survives Nakamura is
going to be getting a confidence
flagging could well be a thing here and
just take a look at shark's clock time
he's under 30 seconds and the moves are
coming as quickly as they can be humanly
made advancing his King into the game
but it feels like this transition is
somewhat easier for shark because he can
make those moves at Tempo huge huge huge
gain for my major of getting the Rooks
off the board without White's Rook it's
going to be harder to hold the pawns
together no passports for white
blackstroke will have a lot of fun on
all the open files
still it's it's anyone's game you feel
50 seconds on the clock is crazy and
black can lose some of the pawns and
Knight E2 was very very good move Knight
F4 now grabbing the H5 though the right
Knight can get in danger after that is
it time for Hikaru to start staking a
claim on the A6 Pawn
yeah White's Bishop does keep that pawn
under watchful gaze and a check which
weighs White's King going though big
decision do you go back block the black
pawns or do you go for Glory with the
white a pawn
lesson 10 seconds for shark he's well
he's nervous you can feel the tension
full Focus Rook moves okay we repeat the
position once more it's a good thing
very stressful pieces are not not
standing in the center of the square
right only seconds on the clock and
that's why the one second increment is
not a lot pieces go flying and Mama
Jarvis going for it we see the
evaluation bar react black is winning
here but it is a race and in a race
situation Anything Can Happen wow really
nice check their manager of throwing a
pawn away to go for the white a pawn
with his Rook
oh pawns are running all over the place
here White's a pawn is it quick enough
the black Brooks found itself trapped
it's incredible the fight is giving he's
trapped his own Rook made that movement
to one second on the clock what's making
a new Queen it is oh anything can happen
here
wow can he save his Knight Nakamura
that's the question or will he promote
he have answered Queen yeah
he's gonna make a queen he wants to move
his Knight I think but uh I don't think
he should get too flamboyant here
oh wow he does move his knife
loses on time
wins the Armageddon game in the closing
seconds but what a battle it looked like
it was going to be a brilliancy for Mama
jarov but Hikaru just so resourceful
kept on defending kept that game alive
and actually Judith you were completely
correct nakamura's final move was a
blunder and uh or at least a mistake and
actually Matt major have played an
excellent move just didn't play it in
time Rook A2 we saw the final move that
he tried to make double exclamation mark
and actually he would have saved it but
the clock does decide his time was so
much down already that it was too long
of a move to make from F2 to A2 at this
point it was hopeless but uh Well Done
by Nakamura I must say yeah I have to
say I was impressed by his
resourcefulness the way that he held on
because I mean his position at one point
looks like it was hopeless well for me
it's not only one point it's more or
less the whole game
but after he started to push his spawns
and stabilize it it was it was clear
that Mohamed jaro was kind of playing
for a draw he wanted he felt that
something went wrong but uh well done by
Nakamura yeah let's just do an action
replay of those final fast furious moves
and uh it was in this position white has
pushed the pawn going forward he's about
to make a new Queen and maybe the best
bet although maybe a losing move would
have been Rook to F1 going behind and we
would have seen the black root give
itself up for the white Pawn we might
have seen a bishop a knight checkmate at
the end there instead Rook takes uh
Bishop happened A7 the queen is
Unstoppable now and after Rook F2
managerov hoping to capture this Knight
I think with a bit more time Hikaru
would simply have made a new Queen and
after Rook takes Knight he would have
found a way uh maybe starting wow
actually yeah winning move here double
attack you spotted it Judith hitting the
Rook at the same time this would have
been a winning opportunity but Hikaru
panicked played Knight to C3 covering
this A2 Square seemingly but actually in
reality Rook to A2 was a brilliant move
the only move to save the game from
mamajarov and if he had more time he
might well have drawn now because Knight
takes Rook is simply met by E2 both
sides make a queen and white tonight is
not enough to win the game the black
pawns should guarantee a draw even
without them this game would have ended
peacefully wow dramatic stuff on the
final move showing how crazy Armageddon
chess can be
that was so frantic it was chaotic at
times it was Armageddon chess it was a
real fight it's what we like to see and
oh let's go to the calmness of the
classical games
and you were also not serious about that
one
and let's uh let's have a quick recap on
the bird's eye view so there's lots of
exciting moments we see alireza pushing
forwards with his King side pawns and
things I've been traded in the game
between Fabiano caruana and gukash
whereas it could be Lively in the our
Anish giri against our entire but we
haven't checked up on one game at all I
think we should pay some attention pay
some love to Wesley so and norderbeck
Abdul sotorov
yes let's uh jump into that battle it's
at move 13 now it's crazy in for example
with the Magnus game they've played nine
moves whereas Nakamura has played two
full games in the same amount of time uh
it just shows this format so many
surprises and uh this is the current
position at move 13 between so and Abdul
satoroff let's do a quick action replay
before we delve into this position to uh
try to get to the to the bottom of it
white is currently a pawn down another
Queen's Gambit accepted we have talked
about this it's the theme the opening of
the tournament seemingly uh this form
was captured E4 met by E5 as we saw in
that first game between Nakamura and
mamadorov right F3 a capture this time
rather than a bishop check and this is
the result Queen F6 after playing an
extremely ambitious line the queen
protecting this Pawn black often wants
to move this bishop out the way and
Castle queenside but this was hit by
Bishop G5 and after the queen
sidestepped Knight to D2 both sides
developing and I think the first
critical moment for me at least was
after this pin
black played a really controversial move
one that I would never have dreamed of
unless uh helped by a computer here
Bishop D6 surely part of Abdus of
torah's preparation walking into a fork
with E5 a double attack here but black
can counter by moving his Knight out the
way for example to H5 hitting this
bishop so this was the Tactical
justification this didn't happen in the
game instead Wesley took a Karma
approach as we used to from him Bishop
G3
trade and after blackcastled Rook to C1
so black is a pawn up but some serious
pressure on the C6 Knight and this black
D4 Pawn might well drop off in the near
future
Judith uh what do you make of this
opening stage
well one thing is for sure that it's
extremely interesting about this uh
standing on the position right now
well white is very energetic I believe
so black black has to be in good shape
and and try to keep up the active play
because otherwise if let's say yeah
Knight G4 is something that the black
can play but then white would be
capturing the C6 Knight and Knight D4
so actually Knight G4 was played yeah
it's played it's on the board and it's
given a question mark not meaning it's a
blunder but just a mistake it's a little
optimistic yeah worsening Black's
position apparently uh you said it
Judith basically the idea is to go for
checkmate later on uh getting into H2
somehow but
looks uh wildly ambitious for black yeah
oh very intriguing game
and uh there we see the two players
focused ready for that action I mean
this is gonna get complicated
and
in the meantime we are joined by
Grandmaster Hikaru Nakamura in the
studio and Hikaru it was a short but
intense day for you today
and basically before the game I looked
at a couple different possibilities
um I just sort of sort of settled on
this Queens game but accepted
um and basically hope that chakra
wouldn't know the line to the end and it
turns out he did so the game was not
really much of a game ended up being
drawn after about 20 minutes but then
this Armageddon game I think more than
made up for it we both had some chances
probably I was losing for much of it but
you sort of just keep the game going and
things seem to work out for me I mean it
did look quite shaky for you the
Armageddon game I have to say I mean how
did you manage to kind of keep the game
alive
um I mean I think the main thing was
just finding ways to pose practical
problems because basically chakra are at
certain point instead of trying to win
the game he was trying to find a
simplification method and so in this end
game with the rookie Bishop at Knight
versus the two Rooks he was always
trying to go for this F4 and just take
H4 and then it's very easy with all the
pawns um so I just tried to prevent that
and just keep the game going and I knew
that if you got really low on time there
was a good chance I'd win because one
second increment is simply not enough
and um but then at the end of course I
blundered right back with this horrible
Knight C3 move I just didn't see Queen
at all and yeah I flagged but yeah it
was a wild day but in the end it was
actually quite funny because the action
of moving The Rook to A2 was actually
the losing move because he lost some
time yeah I I think if he had done it a
little bit quicker we spot the idea
instantly then it would have been fine
um but he didn't spot it instantly
because I think he saw Queen and queen
A6 probably what I completely did not
see and so he was sort of zoned out and
thought he was just going to lose and so
so then he wasn't able to mechanically
play play the move
um but yeah I was just just crazy yeah
and how are you feeling about these
Armageddon games yeah I think uh overall
my score now at least reflects how I've
played I I think when I look at the
overall tournament at least before this
round the one game that I'm very unhappy
with is the Army getting gets Wesley or
I was completely winning and then I
threw it away but today for example I
was completely losing and I won so I
think it's sort of you know it's Justice
in a sense and and now it offsets and so
overall it's pretty good
and I was also going to ask you your
however I was going to ask you you're
very active on the confessional booth
and it's a great Delight for us to hear
your thoughts and to hear your Recaps
but what's it like having that
confessional Booth is it is a good thing
in chair for chess overall well I mean
it depends how you look at it I think
certainly it's a good thing from the
standpoint of giving the spectators more
information
um but the problem of course is most
players don't actually use it because
they're too serious I guess for for lack
of a better way of putting in so I think
because most players are a little bit
too serious they don't use it and I
think certainly the the notion of
in-game interviews or comments or
something in my opinion if you're trying
to make it more popular you almost
should make it mandatory frankly so um I
I don't know if you really can
considering the existing rules of Chess
but I think it's it's only adds to the
game and the the general experience for
the um for The Spectators so I'm all for
it yes not distracting at all well for
me it's not distracting maybe for some
players it is but again I think this
also comes down to the whole like how
serious are you about it versus like uh
versus just like chilling like Magnus
for example is always just relaxed he's
he doesn't much care um you know I'm
pretty much the same way and I think
that it's difficult too though because
for some of the players or maybe a lot
of players and certainly before the rise
of sort of the whole like live streaming
and content creation certainly is that
players tend to be much more um closely
they keep everything closer to the vest
you don't explain as much you don't say
what you're thinking
um in many cases and I will I've said
this on on on air I think on my stream
many times but like one player in
particular where I think that's true of
is levana ronin where there many Casey
does post-game interviews they'll say
that yeah I looked at this line and you
know I looked at this move um when of
course he had not done that at all I
mean it's simply either had forgotten it
or he hadn't looked at all but he made
he made it up as he was going
um and I think a lot of players were
like that including myself but now of
course in this new age you try you try
to be more open and so I think it comes
down to sort of those philosophies of
how like how open are you with the prep
with what you prepared how you feel
about position versus you know not not
being open at all and I think certainly
like for example if you look at Fabiano
I don't think he's done the confessional
at all I'm guessing has he no he hasn't
done the professional whereas if he did
a confessional between his game today
and the game yesterday which are both
Berlin's you'd probably get a pretty
good feel for how he thinks about the
position this this line with Knight B3
with the two Bishops on D6 and E6 and
then today where it's like he has this
Knight on um yeah he's got this Knight
on it's back on D2 but like the knights
on B3 and F3 again very similar sort of
stuff for b3c4 A3 B4 you'll probably get
a lot of insight potentially into what
he thinks about it and so for fabiana's
perspective it's probably not a good
thing to share that so it cuts both ways
yeah and uh talking about insights and
you've been fantastic at giving SEO
insights on the remaining games so do
you want to share with us your thoughts
on uh especially the game between Magnus
Carlsen and alireza furusia
Magnus is just going to smoke him I mean
I think Magnus is already much much
better here uh I sort of alluded to this
in the Confessional As well that there
was a game that I played against Magnus
very specifically I'm pretty sure it was
2013 taught a steal it was a clash of
Sicilian and he played this G3 Bishop G2
and I played H5 H4 got all aggressive
and it failed miserably and I think this
is the exact same thing he provoked
alirez to go for this G5 G4 and now I
mean I just I love magnus's position
here I really really like it yeah do you
think that after he played three Bishop
D3 He did the expected to have G5 on the
board after 1966. probably not G5 but I
think he expected something aggressive
and it's like I said I mean Ali res is
very young of course
um he's he's a lot of emotions I mean
you see it when he plays he definitely
doesn't hide his emotions and I think
for Magus it was just to provoke him get
him do something because Bishop D3
should be dubious like you think it's a
bad move you want to punish it and
probably he didn't look at G5 but
probably he had an idea that alireza
would do something along these lines and
not just play like I don't know like D5
or Knight G7 keep it very very slow well
actually Magnus confessed that he had
not planned he was not preparing at all
against C5 E6 so he just come up with
Bishop D3 and let it be yeah well I mean
but okay even if it's not preparation
though I think if the board is a
psychological choice to play something
offbeat and for alireza it was what E4
c5903 E6 right yeah Bishop d393 oh yeah
so probably Magnus just figured he
didn't want to go into the open he
didn't he didn't really want to I guess
he figured Bishop D3 would be weird
enough that Ali Rosa would do something
aggressive and he was definitely right
and I just I really like magnus's
position here I think I think it's a
great position for white what is it that
makes you like magnus's position so much
here Hikaru well for first of all I I
think Fabiano said this actually before
the match in 2018 when he played against
Magnus Magnus likes King safety when you
look at the current position Black's
king is not safe um if you Castle the
king side like castles maybe there's H3
maybe not but the king doesn't really
feel secure there of course you also
can't Castle as a queen side because you
have the double pawns on C5 and C6 and
so there's no King safety Magnus king of
save there's no attack also to use
another example Gary I remember when I
was working with Gary back in 2011. he
also said that you know Magnus likes to
provoke his opponents likes to get them
to push pawns because the pawns can't go
backwards and so just thinking about
those General general concepts and the
fact that it's simply a position where
you play chess I think Magnus has great
chances here and I'm not really sure
what Ali res is going to do after even a
move like Queen E1 I mean if you Castle
there's Queen H4 if you play A5 you can
always go A4 and then down the road some
Bishop D2 and queen E1 also threatens E5
to weaken those pawns on D6 and C5 so
yeah it just looks bad and you can't go
E5 except F5 so where's the play
how surprised are you that Magnus did
not win a classical game so far
um mildly surprised but he hasn't played
great so he's finally getting just just
getting to play chess here and I think
um you know he's gonna win today so
that's the question for the past
what do you make of your chances in the
tournament now of catching Fabi I mean
it depends on the current position which
I haven't seen for a while
um let's let's bring it up for you then
yeah let's bring that game up
oh it's actually petering out though
right it's looking yeah it's looking
pretty uh
it feels like it should be Josh but
Fabian is just going to be up a pawn
here's what it looks like right queen
queen takes C5 Queen takes D3 Queen
takes C7 uh but then there's Rook C8
so I mean Bobby's gonna try to grind him
Fabiano wins it's it's over but I mean
we'll see
you play each other in the final round
uh if you're within touching distance
you fancy your chances yeah I'll give it
my best shot but again we have to get
there first and I mean Fabiano is a
pretty nice position right now I would
say and the other storyline is this
battle for world number two does that
how much does that mean to you nah it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter at all
if you play good chess good things
happen
true why is the words couldn't be said
and uh tomorrow is a free day do you
have any plans no no I have to go and
get ready for title Tuesday and stream
so uh I'll worry about tomorrow when we
get there
both both events or just the one well
one's already started so I can't get
back and play oh okay one at like 11 or
something so of course I'll be playing
okay nothing better to do
and what's been your like pre-game
ritual here in Norway
um I haven't had a pre-game ritual I
think just in general
um
you know I just try to prepare a little
bit for the rounds for like an hour or
two I try to sleep because the rounds
are so late so it's like I go eat lunch
at two sleep from three to four prepare
for like 30 minutes and then then come
and play and um that's pretty much it
and is there anything that you find very
helpful that's not chats for playing
chess
um
not really not ready all I do is more
chess anyway with Recaps and things like
that so it's only chess
well thank you very much Hikaru for
joining us here in the studio and I'd
like to wish you good luck in the
remaining two games and we're looking
forward to hearing more from your
confessionals we really enjoy them a lot
thank you very much
and wow what an exciting start to the
seventh round I I mean what an intense
match we were treated to there by Hikaru
and Shakira mamajarov both players
playing very dynamically with a lot of
energy
it's a perfect combination oh absolutely
that was a very fun game to follow and
to see how things can turn over right
for mamajaro if he played so well the
opening he made this sacrifice
everything turned out to be good he was
just
fire on the board he made the best move
for some time and then somehow a little
bit he started to get back and then it
was a little drawish but there was no
Force draw so that was the problem
ultimately it felt like the most
experienced player for Blitz won
so anyhow that was a very exciting very
captivating and I think it's time to
take a break and catch our breaths
a pop or cups of teas up cups of coffees
and we'll see you in a few minutes
struggling to improve your game
chessable is the home for chess
improvers with hundreds of courses by
incredible authors like world champion
Magnus Carlson Christoph selecki andras
Toth everyone's favorite social media
troll known as Anish Geary and so many
more chessable can help you raise your
game to the next level
you're getting started on the
fundamentals you should check out
everyone's first chess workbook maybe
you want to stop letting all those
points slip away in the end game 100 end
games you must know is the course for
you
did you not notice your king was in
check and still can't figure out why the
pieces won't move
actually uh chessable can't help you
with that maybe try refreshing your tab
check out chessable today and get 30
days of pro for free go to chessable.com
begin
is uh is anybody in snoops Camp playing
chess is that happening or not I haven't
seen it there's some smart people in the
camp so I wouldn't be surprised if
people
R versus edit
a lot of college educated people you
know I unfortunately am not one of those
sophisticated people that play chess in
the camp she talking about man I don't
play chess
I mean you know how to play I listen
there's a difference with knowing how to
start a car up and then driving Formula
One racing
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
land of fjords Majestic mountains Cliffs
and waterfalls
in addition to stunning geography Norway
is home to the greatest chess player who
has ever lived Magnus Carlson
since 2013 Norway has also hosted one of
the strongest chess super tournaments in
the world and it is one for which Magnus
has claimed the top prize in the last
four years
can anyone stop him
this time he'll meet one of his toughest
Challenges ever at his home tournament
with nine Rivals all hungry to beat the
best
from Carlson's fiercest online rival
today in their first classical
over-the-board battle in nearly four
years Hikaru Nakamura
to the young star Carlson once
hand-picked as his most worthy
Championship opponent alireza farrugia
two more young stars are trying to
follow in his footsteps laude Beck Abdul
sotorov and kukesh domaraju
two established stars have already won a
Super tournament in 2023. Anish giri and
Fabiano caruana
two more long-time Headliners seek to
take their next turn Atop A major
tournament Wesley so and shakuria
Mahmoud yarov
finally Carlson's Countryman and friend
ariantari rounds out the field
who will come out on top will Carlson
run the table yet again or will someone
else usurp the throne this
is Norway chess
hello and welcome back everybody and
it's been a Fast and Furious start to
round seven we've already had one match
finish and it went all the way to
Armageddon it was short it was sweet but
it was very intense and there we saw
Hikaru Nakamura defeat shakuria
mamajarov and before the break we had
Hikaru in the studio sharing with us his
thoughts you know telling us that he
felt that now his score actually
reflected his play and he was very
pleased to have won an Armageddon game
just like that against chakra mamajarov
well he seemed like kind of happy with
his result of course he felt that there
something was going wrong in the
Armageddon right but I see that he's
getting tired kind of at the same time
he's doing great in the tournament he's
keeping his second place I believe and
it was interesting to see him talking
about other things also a lot of
insights on on Magnus also and the other
games yeah and I was a bit surprised
actually that his why I guess I wasn't
that surprised but uh he was telling us
that his life was just chess so if you
know if he wasn't doing this he was
gonna go back and play title Tuesday and
then do a YouTube recap and then stream
some more
and in in the pauses during the games
you know he's there in the confessional
chatting chess I believe that he just
simply enjoys it a lot and it makes him
uh enjoy it in a fun way
yeah he's the most productive manager so
that's for sure and I guess it's only 24
hours in the day he has to cram it all
in somehow but it's nice to hear that
he's still so in love with the game
after so many years it was kind of funny
when he said that well maybe it should
be obligatory to should everybody should
go to the confessional Booth yeah I
thought that was quite nice and also he
gave us some insights on how he had
worked with Kasparov how they had
identified one of magnus's techniques
which was to provoke the opponents to
push forward with their pawns and uh
just destabilize their own Kings
well in the meantime actually we have
some incredible updates on the game of
Magnus which actually Nakamura described
that he will win today it's like no
question about it and some very
interesting things are going on
yeah some huge developments in that game
between Magnus and farrugia we see them
on the camera we'll jump into the game
in a moment but as you say Jude really
dramatic stuff and uh this is the
head-to-head Magnus did nominate or did
go on record saying that alireza faruja
would be the only player he was
interested in playing a world
championship match against of course A
Clash of the generations big age
difference between these two and uh
farush has been one of the best players
in the world for a long long time now
but Magnus is leading their head to head
quite significantly especially in the
classical four wins to zero in classical
chess and uh that's where we start of
course here in OHS if it goes down to
Rapid if he goes to the Armageddon
things much closer there with farusha
having taken four wins himself but
Magnus in the lead there too
sign of things to come maybe well I
think when you have such a great result
against someone and you play with the
white pieces and you're number one in
the world you have all the
self-confidence that maybe you can just
repeat what he did in the previous four
uh games or what he won
so it's psychologically is an advantage
to play when you have this kind of score
against your opponent
um do you think that has influenced some
of his decisions over the last couple of
moves Judith I think we have to jump in
and show uh those dramatic moments that
have happened yes probably it does be
have such a good score against your
opponent you know that maybe I can
afford myself a little riskier decisions
and that has been reflected in his last
couple of moves when Hikaru was with us
it uh let's do an action replay here
let's jump in uh Hikaru was with us in
this position after Knight to E7 and
here he was suggesting very logical
moves such as Queen to E1 I liked oh I
love that decision from Macaro Magnus
found something even more ambitious a
pawn sacrifice he played Bishop to D2
and this of course drops the B2 Pawn but
it wasn't a blunder it was a
well-calculated sacrifice uh faruja took
up the challenge Bishop takes Pawn
trapping the white rook in the corner
but this was met by Bishop to A5 not
quite trapping The Black Queen kicking
her to D7 and now Knight to D2 yesterday
we talked about the score sheets how you
would write certain moves down her
Magnus for sure calling this Knight one
to D2 because there's two knights on the
B file and after Knight one to these two
shoot it you're the attacker here great
attacking chance I can tell you the
truth I'm really Amazed by this decision
what Magnus did Bishop D2 Bishop A5
giving up a very important Pawn after
all on B2 and now there is a big
question that is firoza going to capture
the and take the Rook on A1 because so
far we've seen in most of these kind of
situations when the exchange was offered
usually the players prefer to keep the
bishop in such a cases so this is a very
big question at the same time What do
you do you do you take the Rook or you
want to move back with the bishop to
safety on G7 I think the idea behind
Bishop D2 and Bishop A5 is that it stops
Black's coordination completely look at
the bishop on C8 where is it going to be
going right and after the fact that the
Knight has placed it it on B3 D5 is not
possible to break out because the C5 is
under attack so it will be very
difficult for black
to develop properly and the King indeed
will stuck on E8 for a moment it seems
to be okay and in safety but in the long
run it can be very tricky so the idea is
very interesting
yeah fascinating and super ambitious and
okay fairuzia doesn't Ponder too long he
does not take the bait and I think we
have to show that uh just for
instructive purposes why black didn't
take the extra material there uh he
played Bishop back to G7 if uh let's
jump in now if he had taken on a one of
the White Queen would have infiltrated
on the dark squares all of the dark
squares would have belonged to White and
we see the evaluation bar immediately
react in White's favor despite black
being significantly ahead now in terms
of points uh this is a big hit on The
Rook you can never dream of castling
your king in this type of situation the
White Queen would simply uh penetrate
here and this is going to be game over
the white Bishop coming in and checkmate
imminent quite an amazing idea by Magnus
yeah just beautiful just sensing color
complexes squares and control and also
yeah the black pieces as you said you'd
have just unable to fight back so okay
Bishop G7 keeping control over the dark
squares at least before the bishop gets
trapped uh Behind Enemy Lines and white
has gained two or three Tempi in return
for that pawn how to justify it well now
rugby one is something to be played not
because it's attack then do you want to
move it away from the attacking square
but maybe to have the Uruk on B1 it can
be useful unless there is a better
option maybe at some point already F5
can be very powerful in the game
yeah I have five going on the attack
that was also something that I was
considering and uh one thing that also
crossed my mind was actually to
potentially break with the pawn on E5 as
well just to completely ruin Black's
Pawn structure
yeah I think this would be a lovely idea
especially if we can get the white
knight into E4 he just has to time it
right Magnus the bar doesn't drop too
much so definitely viable definitely on
the cards uh watch out for this idea
Hikaru alluded to it himself uh Hikaru
for example was suggesting to move Queen
E1 and I can't take my eyes off that
move ever since he mentioned it just
again with the idea of your suggestion
that Ivanka E5 if the black king ever
castles then the White Queen jumps
already out to the queen side
uh sorry to the king side there
yeah really rich position full of life
uh Curious that the computer thinks it's
dead level even though Hikaru was 100
sure Magnus is going to win this one
let's see if for Asia can keep things
intact
yeah
very uh very unusual position on the
table here
um shall we go back to the bird's eye
view and have a look at some of the
other games and there is one game that I
have my eye on it looks very dry
potentially even boring
but I'm wondering whether a draw is on
the cards for Fabiana caruana and kukash
and by that I'm kind of hinting at will
they agree a draw
quite soon
and we see gokesh on the picture there
let's check out what's happened in that
game
uh since yeah since iCarly left us
Queens are off the board and it's still
Level material the only imbalance here
being the fact that black has a passport
an isolated Pawn however on C5 and
another isolani the E6 Pawn potentially
weak as well Judith first instincts is
it going to be a draw
well I believe so that it's going to be
a draw because black does have a
weakness on E6 but there is nothing to
no peace which I it can attack it and
the the pawn on C5 is actually a strong
pass spawn so there is a good chance
that it will be staying there like for
example white is going Rook B5 Black
Goes C4 C3 so black is really one to
push that bone right so it's a strong
pass spawn probably white should be
playing bringing the king to King F1 and
after C4 maybe Rook C1 King E2 and
trying to stabilize and bring the the
king into the center but uh well now
Knight F3 of course it has a lot of
sense it wants to jump to E5 and attack
the Knight The Rook
but I'm not sure whether is this a big
deal for example uh if Black Goes C4
which is the most obvious move of course
Knight E5 is
is asked
but after that Rook C5 is possible but
also after Rook D6 I'm not sure how
white will be making such a big
Advantage probably look C1 Rook D4 F3
let's show this on the board it's very
likely to happen as you mentioned there
Judith uh what else simply well of
course Knight D7 also makes sense though
after that uh yeah C4 the Knight E5 yep
f97 at least white can hope to get
active and let's see uh See for the most
direct passports about to be pushed
after all so Knight E5 yeah let's say
Knight E5 and then
Rook D6
but after rule D6 maybe white is going
to play Rook C1
Rook D4
though it's not threatening to take on
C4 but still anyway the Knight on E5
stands extremely well so white can go F3
and then King F2
yeah kick this Rook away if possible and
eventually try to round up this spawn
might become a bit of a racier if
White's quick enough
yeah we have C4 on the board but I think
after Knight E5
there is a good chance black wants to go
Rook C5
counter attacking the Knight on E5 and
if F4 then black can go C3
nice although if I take this
right now ah sorry C2 you go Knight D3
yeah
so this was not my plan it's a
misunderstanding
so F4 maybe the critical position
no then Rook C5 I'm not so happy
probably though Knight A4 is possible
but then Rook B4
yeah rugby four hitting the Knight
hitting the pawn also some checkmating
attacks against the black king if uh
black is a bit careless
I'm already thinking three actually wait
can I give a check maybe yeah maybe
checking Knight D7 yeah maybe I hit your
rook and threaten a nasty check on f8 so
some
concerns for black in this position yeah
okay well well we'll see what happens
here between these two players it is
looking like it will head into a draw
but let's check out the bird's eye view
and uh let's go over to the game between
Wesley so and noribbeck Abdus because
look at that the evaluation bar is right
in the black side so that means white is
doing very very well isn't he just a
pawn up yeah and there's some crazy
tactics on the board a capture of a porn
a hit on the black queen was met by a
simple bishop move and we could see the
Queens coming off in a really odd
convoluted way there we see Wesley took
the black queen and incidentally
nordebec captures the White Queen and
we'll do an action replay in a few
moments but Judah I think uh your bank
is right it looks like black will
eventually kind of come out of this down
material so many weak Pawns in the black
well that's very much how it seems so
black has no material loss yet I I can
say but it's very close because the C7
Pawn will be very weak and at the same
time also we can say I think that D4 is
also more of a weakness than a strong
pass spawn
and also the pieces are kind of
everywhere right the bishop on A4 is not
stable it should be standing somewhere
on E6 the Knight on G4 is basically when
they're about seven eight moves ago with
the ideas of attack but there is nothing
left from that yeah I I do like that you
accidentally highlighted the E6 square
and I was like yes you should the Knight
should be standing on E6
if only they could be moved diagonal I
highlighted that on purpose Judy was
saying the bishop wanted to be on E6 but
something wants to be on E6 that's for
sure Ivanka
yeah Bishop here or a knight if uh if
possible just anchored by a pawn I think
really instructive uh Bishops Knights
they love to be protected by their pawns
and yeah let's just do a quick action
replay because we left this a few moves
ago to see how we got here Wesley's
definitely turned things in his favor
and I think the culprit the guilty party
here was Knight to G4 this ambitious
move uh you mentioned it judic going for
checkmate trying to somehow get the
queen across bring it down to H2 but
this square is simply protected and very
straightforward play from Wesley he
simply captured a knight wrecked the
black porn structure Queen to A4 hitting
this Pawn hitting this D4 pawn and Quint
H6 don't really understand it I've got
to say still no threats on the board
White tonight's protect everything just
allowed Rook date C6 and okay a clever
idea from nordebec this pin this counter
hit here but
yeah this is the current position Rook
takes Queen Bishop takes Queen and Rook
C1 is coming uh Rook C5 is coming and
Wesley so is incredibly a good player in
such a positions especially when he has
just a little Advantage maybe maybe big
Advantage I'm not sure about that but
one thing is sure that white is going to
be placing his Rook probably to C5 from
H5 the D4 Pawn probably will fall off
and uh somehow black is in huge trouble
yeah no coordination weak Pawns
yeah it looks like a bit of a disaster
especially against a technician like
Wesley so and the A4 Bishop is really
standing badly
because for example after Black Goes
Rook d8 if we just dive into some moves
black white plays Rook C5 I believe
after Rook 88 maybe Rook A5 immediate
living's material
but if let's say Rook FDA it goes
go and be on the safe side somehow then
Rook C5
and there are already now black cannot
defend with Rook D7 because B3 is
trapping the bishop so you can feel how
dangerously plays the bishop on ea4 it
needs time to get back to safety but
what about the Pawns
yeah how do you defend this Pawn within
the next couple of moves on C7 how do
you defend the D4 Pawn now very
difficult to think of a good counter
play
yeah the only thing that I can think of
is uh actually
and again it carries its risk
I mean you've got to defend D4 for for
starters as you both highlighted and I
was thinking C6 as being the only way to
defend C7
so you know you know no you but you
can't allow now it takes porn yeah after
Rook FDA trook C5 you go C6 C6 and
it's ugly but then even then Rook C4 is
just going to win material Bishop Bishop
B5 yeah so for now I think Rook F1 to C1
yeah maybe I could start with uh one two
c one here hitting the pawn yes that's
also possible because after C6
immediately B3 and A4 and grabbing the
pawn right
yeah this Rook is really nice actually
on H5 no need to commit it yet
swing anywhere at once along the fifth
rank
gotta say
I have to agree with you both I mean the
only thing that I've just tutorial can
kind of thank his lucky stars for is
maybe the porn on D4 maybe he says okay
I give up the C Pawn get some counter
play somehow or another
pray yeah pray and the problem is you
have this beautiful past Pawn on the
default but Knights are the best
blockadas and whitesnites keep that
black born under lock and key
it's the rest of the position that is
falling apart for black and I think we
can see in the body language I'm very
curious how Noddy Iraq will be able to
create an account to play
because it just looks so much that the
the position is falling apart
yeah looks like a very difficult job for
nordeback but we'll see what he can
manage he is a fantastic player he's
great technician but there's one game we
haven't really looked at for a long time
that's the game between Anish giri Ari
antari good friends also our antari was
the second for Niche giri and
boom how's it going for Aryan aryan's
been having a very rough tournament so
far is he on track to get some points
well there is a pawn up for an issue
right so to start with and we see a
question mark there
on the last move of Tori and let's
figure out why is that but I have the
feeling that white will keep simply a
pawn up
yeah the question is whether our uh here
Anish sorry has more than just winning
uh a pawn and going maybe into a rook
end game for example initially leaning
back in his chair there and uh let's
maybe do a recap I just don't understand
what black has in mind after d takes E5
yes because she can go go back and see
how we got it yeah first just a few
moves uh let's go back because we left
it here uh just seven eight moves ago
Queen C2 and uh very natural moves Rook
C8 A4 trying to chip away at Black's
Pawn chain this erosion was blocked by
A6 and after a trade of Pawns just from
very very natural moves here and after
Knight C3 maybe the first big decision
of the game Ariane giving up the pawn
this is how we reach this Pawn down
decision uh he simply castled his King
ignoring the threats on B5 and after
castles maybe he'd underestimated that
after Knight takes B5 now Knight B4 does
not win a piece because the Blackfish 27
has been lured away has been tricked
away no longer defending the knights on
B four so White's Queen and Knight can
save each other after the move simply
Queen to D2 and after Bishop takes
Knight the Black Knight Falls and yeah
Judy big question here black will have
compensation due to the uh kind of
presence of potentially opposite color
Bishops but E5 very committal stuff yes
because I'm wondering isn't that
possible to take with the pawn and after
Bishop C3 to take he takes F6
and if Bishop G2 then F takes G7
takes takes takes takes takes it's a
bunch of captures but at the very end if
we take one last Rook white takes
another rook and yeah we get to this end
game with white being two pawns up not
just one and this is clearly winning
four versus two on the king side it's
gonna be an easy conversion so he must
have something in mind maybe Judah is it
Queen takes porn here that he's hoping
for and the big question here would be
yes absolutely this is the only move to
be uh playing but uh White seems to have
a very good bone yeah it's an extra what
about Queen C3 for example that is one
pry
but of course black tries to have
compensation for the pawn that's a
clear-cut at the same time I'm not sure
he will be able to get enough
compensation because if the if there
would be a rook end game with four
against three with four Rooks on the
board I think that can be still very
tricky because with one pair of Rooks
it's a draw
but with two pairs of Rook I think even
then it would be a lot to play on and
I'm not sure black can get it
yeah I have well it is looking like a
struggle for Ariane but before the game
started we can see in this video that
Anish and Aryan had some fun during
tari's interview and uh there you can
see them laughing around they are having
a good giggle some banter between the
two David I have to ask is it weird to
play against your second
uh yeah I find it hard playing against
someone I like someone I respect uh
especially with the second Dynamic where
they've discussed openings together but
it's nice to see a bit of humor there
just a bit of playfulness from a niche
uh how about you you did it did you
enjoy that during your career playing
against someone a friend a second
[Music]
which were the with the trainer in one
tournament
but it's uh I think if you're
professional you can handle that and it
goes okay you think uh-huh because I was
really curious like recently with Dane
Lauren in his world championship match
he was working with Richard Richard was
like that Bastion of support and then
they went off and they played a
tournament
and I was like hmm isn't that a bit
weird yeah of course it depends on what
level do you know each other because
when I was playing a game with the
training partner or maybe knew what to
avoid and then everything was okay of
course we wanted to beat each other but
before and after the game the
relationship stayed the same uh yeah
some in some cases it can be very tricky
also in things situation but I think
they find a way and if you have a
healthy approach then it goes well and I
have to ask is it written into the
contract
you cannot play this against me
um guys do spill the secrets I never had
something like that I always trusted the
common sense but I can imagine that
maybe some of the really top guys like
Magnus I can imagine that it might
yeah I won't reveal too much but I have
seen some contracts and and some are
stricter than others let's say I think
some players really don't care they're
happy to let their seconds kind of reap
the rewards of their work but some are a
bit stricter uh-huh um no names included
yeah because we had this kind of
situation I remember with Fabiana
Carolina you know he was training rustam
kazir majana for a long time and then
there was a breakup and uh kind of
rustam was kind of talking about
the opening lines as being the children
so to speak
and they were in negotiations I said who
could keep the children who could visit
their children
and that that actually brings uh us to
Yesterday When Fabiano uh played against
new partner in crime uh Abdul sotorov uh
interesting when there's a second who
suddenly jumps around I mean Magnus for
example has been working with Peter
heinenson for years who previously
worked with Anand magnus's predecessor
so Mind Games there all over the place
and it's not just there as well because
uh of course Magnus has worked with Jan
gustavson on the world championship prep
and now young Gustafson is a close
second of Anish so oh all interconnected
sharing is caring brings us all back to
that
and uh meanwhile Anish he's enjoying his
position despite the body language I
think Ariane has a lot of suffering
ahead unfortunately for him it feels
like again another two result game it
seems to be the theme of his tournament
ever since a Mr opportunity in the early
rounds every game he's fighting for the
draw and nothing more and uh looking at
the bird's eye view I can see that uh
Judith and David you've been spot on
with some of your predictions Fabiano
um not and they're not a big game
norderbeck did go for that
counter-attack against the Knight and uh
Hikari actually mentioned when he was
here with us before the break that he
was really attracted to this queen E1
move and sure enough that is the move
that's appeared in the Magnus Carlson
Ali Reza faruja game
not just any odd move either Magnus
Carlson's last move predicted the idea
predicted by Hikaru has been awarded a
double exclamation mark by the
All-Seeing all-knowing computer
impressive move there and it's
unexpected because it still continues
this theme of giving up the exchange
tempting black to take this rook in the
corner which we've already showed that
would actually transpose
uh definitely not a good idea beautiful
move there Queenie one and incidentally
Magnus has been in the confessional
Booth I think he did the the audio in
Norwegian and basically a quick
translation he says he's very happy with
himself there's Bishop D2 Bishop A5 and
Knight D2 maneuver very important he
says he thinks he's doing well and he
does close with a little caveat saying
but he's been proven wrong before
yeah a number four Magnus would not add
that last sentence but uh he has had
some very promising positions that he
hasn't finished off this tournament
should it well yesterday he had a very
promising position which he misplayed it
completely in the classical game versus
story but I feel that today he is really
in his powerful Magnus mode
way so far for sure it certainly does
and I just you know we just you just
reminded me of a conversation that we
had earlier on when we were talking
about what are the qualities one needs
to be able to get to the top in chess
like for instance do you need to be
confident like or do you need to be
aggressive do you need to be a
perfectionist what do you guys think
well you have to have a lot of skills I
believe to be on the top first of all
you have to be extremely hungry for a
chance yeah you have to have the passion
and love for it working on it endlessly
hours that your hand head is ticking
about chest wherever you go
and you do everything in order to
perform the best you can and of course
perseverance is something you have to
have you have to have resilience you
have to be someone who has good nerves
good sleeping habits and keep the focus
as much as possible and stay motivated
yeah just to name a few
yeah all of the above okay it's yeah
it's a combination It's a combination of
uh a lot of things I think it's
basically everything you need to be good
at life kind of good at business good at
sports is you need to kind of put it
together uh for the chess as well and
you need to be versatile just ready to
adapt ready to take the losses take the
hits and uh to bounce back and yeah
Hikaru showed it you need to just eat
breathe sleep chess yes and I'm kind of
curious about the issue of confidence
and confidence in your own ability
because I I don't know why but some
video propped up of a famous footballer
Zlatan who was like well known for
having
massive ego you know when he moved over
to La he literally took out an advert
which says La you're welcome
to be an asset when it comes to the
chessboard that you know you have
tremendous faith in yourself I think
it's absolutely a must to have your
self-confidence and self-confidence
comes from good results and performances
uh healthy self-confidence is a must to
perform whether you're a chess player or
you're going to an exam right and it's
also not only about yourself but also
that your opponent fills it that you
have uh you have your self-confidence
and it means a lot in progressing and
becoming a great player I believe
yeah I'm nothing that quotes on the
screen Zlatan doesn't play football
football plays laughter
yeah and uh the top the top players in
any sport I think uh they have that
confidence because they've shown it day
in day out they've proved it to
themselves and this was also chat as
mentioning a great story about Zlatan
which says that LeBron James sends
Zlatan a football shed
signed and Zlatan sent it back with his
own signature I mean it's crazy
uh we're gonna miss him I can't believe
he's retired one of my favorite players
uh Zlatan but uh yeah it's it's
definitely a case of who's the Zlatan in
chess these days all of them are kind of
exuding the same self-confidence Hikaru
Magnus yeah I would even say like there
are some players who are quietly
confident like ding I would put them
although he did worry me during the
World Championship when he actually was
like super open about his mental state
and he said you know what I was
confident because he did some pre-game
interviews where he was like yeah yeah
I'm happy to be here I'm feeling very
confident and then came game one and
then he was like actually you know what
I'm struggling and I don't like my hotel
and I'm going to move out of my hotel
and everyone was like whoa never seen
that boom before you know it was very
interesting when I was reading that he
he was not sure that he really wants to
become a world champion and when he was
playing that after he is going to
lose the match he's going to be retired
yeah so when I was reading this I was
thinking whether is he really serious
because that would kind of explain some
of the behaving things what he was
saying and the way he was
acting so I was wondering I'm puzzled
with that yes ever since
well well we'll find out later on in the
year what happens there but uh the
players are deep in thought and now it's
the perfect time to take a break so
we'll see you in a few minutes
stay tuned
dude it's impossible to not hear you
just breathing super loudly okay fine I
will hold my breath for three minutes
all right let's go okay let's go right
now just clock app right here almost
there and you did it
what can you do for three minutes my
wife says not a lot but I can play keep
that big butt down dude nice
two one you did it wow I feel better oh
yeah oh you were timing me yeah you were
in there for 30. oh man let's play some
chess and get some dinner let's do it
time lapse yeah okay you bring a clock
oh I left my clock at home dude you
idiot I told you to bring it let's just
go get somebody okay
download the new chess.com clock app so
you can time yourself playing chess or
whatever other dumb stuff you and your
friends do
I do like positional styled games I may
try to keep it positional but I I I can
also uh change gears and I think that's
very important in terms of uh you know
anyone trying to develop their chess
game
um if you do find you know style of play
that you enjoy that's good but you could
also try to sharpen it by implementing
you know another form of uh into your
bag as we would call it
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
hello and we are back in action and it's
been relatively calm after the storm
that was Hikari and Shakira mamajar of
the players are deep in thought or
contemplating what they're going to be
doing next but there's been some
critical moments on the board and of
course everything is lining up really
nicely for the bit the final two rounds
because there is a lot of stake there's
a take a look at the prize money
have a look
have you ever seen such big prize money
before
well there are tournaments where they
have a good price money and this is
quite significant yeah what we have here
yeah and first of all Let's uh refresh
our minds on the standing Fabiana
caruana is in the lead with 13 and a
half points out of 18. Hikaru Nakamura
is in second but because he defeated
Shaq in that Armageddon he now moves up
to 12 and a half points so if Fabi for
some reason loses Hikaru is snapping at
his heels alireza farouza does have the
black pieces against Magnus and kukash
is facing off against Fabiano caruana
and in sixth place Magnus Carlsen seven
and a half points
but
Magnus and ferrugia such a critical game
I would say that one is the most
exciting one out of the lot
that's very exciting and it is very
interesting for me that as Magnus
things of alireza so high he was really
the player he wanted to be playing if he
would decide to defend his title let's
say it was very clear he was very open
about it I think it means that maybe
also he came today with the with the
mindset that okay today it's going to be
an interesting game and finally I'm
going to win but for sure it's going to
be a very interesting and challenging
game because with firoza we know that
you don't have to provoke him too much
to make some moves like also today he
was doing G5 right so sometimes you play
with opponents who you can make sure
that they will make the game interesting
and with those people it's very good to
play yeah and I wish to remind ourselves
what is at stake
it's not just the pride the love the
glory it's also a lot of money first
place will walk away with 750
000 Krona
and second four hundred thousand krona
and a 2.5 million Norwegian krona total
prize fund that's very impressive
yeah that's a great price found and this
is usually what's going on in most of
the events online and offline events
that they have a very significant
hundreds of thousands of dollars of
prize money and then it's divided who
plays the best takes the more the most
and uh when you say millions of anchor
it sounds like a lot we should mention
for our American audience out there
divided by 10 and you get pretty much
the similar amount in dollars so about
75 000 that's still a lot for first
price and uh life-changing especially
for some of the younger players who need
to fund their way uh fund their coaching
for the more established Stars this is
uh the norm hopefully inspiring some of
the younger viewers at home to get
involved with chess absolutely but it's
interesting you know that even though
they are playing with such a huge at
stake in the money wise and of course
for cash and other record obviously
they've never won such money it would be
really the first time and it's so
impressive when you're professional and
you're playing at the board you cannot
think about money you have to think
about the position about your
preparation about your general feeling
and how you prepare for it it cannot be
on your mind what has to be in your mind
to focus on the game and get the best
result you can and after that you look
around so how much money I'm collecting
for all this I did
so you're saying when you agree to play
a tournament you never check the price
fund you just said yeah of course you
you see the price found you you do all
these things and you're aware of the
things and of course I'm sure everybody
sees what is the last prize also just a
picture
I'm just saying that when you're playing
when you're fighting it out when you
decide on a move you're not simply the
those things are not on my own yeah they
shouldn't be on your mind but uh it
certainly is can be a factor as David's
kind of indicated especially for someone
like Ari antara you know if he were to
win 750 000 Norwegian krona which is
roughly 75 000 US dollars that would be
life-changing for him yeah exactly it
will take the pressure off in future
events he's uh I think as Hikaru as well
has said now that he's no longer a
professional player he thinks of himself
as a streamer the pressure's off he can
take more risks at the board it's not
all about the prize money and it kind of
gives you a more objective feel I know
from my experience I always play best
when I'm not aware of the price money or
not thinking about it and probably my
most heartbreaking defeats have always
been in the final rounds when I've
calculated in advance the difference
between winning drawing losing and the
money's influencing my decisions at the
board uh in the final round of one grand
Swiss I knew how much I would make it
with a win in the final round and that
blinded me at the board to make some bad
decisions and of course I ended up with
nothing so that's uh that's just how the
way the world works unfortunately
um there's more important things yeah
and I'm kind of curious about that story
I mean did you take more aggressive
risks or did you perhaps take more
negative risk like like for instance
passive Place passively yeah I mean more
kind of ambitious risks I knew with a
win in the final round I would qualify
for the candidates I mean first prize in
the groundswiss alone was a huge amount
of money last place in the candidates
huge amount of money
um and I knew that a draw would be
decent but a loss would be pretty much
nothing and I kind of just took a gamble
in a dead level position which backfired
immediately because I was so fixated on
that kind of prize the pot of gold at
the end of the rainbow when actually I
should have been thinking about the
first two steps three steps uh instead
and it ruined what was a fantastic
tournament so
um yeah I know a lot of these players
have had similar kind of bad beat
stories uh similar heartbreaks and their
professional life not to be thinking
about that I know Magnus probably hasn't
thought about prize money for years
walking away from the world championship
with that uh huge price fund as well I
think players are many times I mean the
top players they are not thinking about
money when they are playing I believe
but if let's say you play in the Olympic
and it's a matter of gold or silver or
any medal then it can be also sneaking
into your mind how do you decide you
don't get to sleep in the night before
you know I once had a story that uh a
team that they shall remain nameless
they were not paid anything but they
were given both like bonuses so if they
got the gold medal there I think they
would get a fifty thousand dollar bonus
and if they got silver medal then it
would be 25
000 and well someone lost they also will
remain nameless and they got silver
instead of gold and then you see them
all on the podium and all of them are
like
okay
they're so annoyed
I've given away the country though with
the currency that you named the bonus
prices did I okay let's move on I didn't
oh okay maybe I didn't I absolutely
didn't okay it wasn't that team
mysterious but yeah either way it does
play a factor right in how players
perceive tournaments we often say that
uh we forget all our wins we just
remember the losses one loss is far more
painful than kind of the joy of a
thousand wins and especially if you end
up end a tournament on a loss at least a
sour taste oh yeah oh yeah that's that's
uh that's a very sad story yeah okay so
everyone there hasn't been too much
movement in any of the games but uh
shall we take a quick look at the
Fabiana caruana good cash game because
we were kind of alluding to the fact
earlier that it could and in a draw very
soon
there is some a little bit Improvement
and changes on Fabiano's favor because
black had to move to much worse position
than night as it was before because it
back went back to ca to the eighth Rank
and it's it's very passive and it has a
significant distance from the pawn the
postpone which we were talking about
that the pawn should be
pretty strong at the same time when you
have your night so far away it can
become very weak if white is managing to
play King closer to the center to play
Rook C1 and then the C3 can be
vulnerable and if black loses that pawn
then objectively the game is won for
Fabiano and I think then go cash will
not be able to save the game yeah we
could see a key few moves here Judah as
you mentioned if kukash doesn't find the
right path then Fabi might win and
pretty much seal the tournament with a
couple of rounds to spare and uh maybe
we can also do an action replay because
kokesh found an only move end games they
tend to be a bit dry in general tend to
be hard to understand I struggled with
end games when I was young but if we
just backtrack to the final the previous
position we saw after the move F4 which
you predicted dude Knight C8 was pretty
much the only move to keep the balance
these end games are so tricky this is
actually where 90 of games are decided
in the final stages and uh yeah this was
simply that Rook B8 doesn't come with a
check black could start running the pawn
and after King F2 C3 Knight to D3 you
mentioned that the stakes are high
despite the fact this is quite
simplified Judith what would you do how
would you defend this position as black
I think Rook C4 is a must this is what
I'm thinking immediately looking for
counter chances so now the E4 Pawn is
attacked and if let's say white plays
King E3 then the Knight can activate
itself to D6 and immediately the
position is uh is uh seemingly looking
much better than it was for black maybe
Knight has to go back to F2 but in that
case the White Knight becomes passive so
this is how it goes back and forth and I
think this position is very fragile for
gokash so he has to be extremely precise
in the next three four Moves In order to
simplify or just get the position where
he secures his uh
his draw and these young players are so
sharp they're so good at calculating
kakesh of course finds an alternative
they always defend the most active way
and this hit on the black Rook was met
by counter-attacking uh move C2 pretty
much forcing the white Rook uh to make a
decision maybe step in front of the pawn
Fabi instant move this game is suddenly
sped up and maybe he's thinking about
the same idea there we go Rook to C4
he's just made the white Rook passive
first
yeah interesting uh so I think this was
the other way of doing it but the main
idea is to have the Rook on this Force
rank I think it's very important to look
for counter chances because white spawn
structure is very strong in the center
with E4 and F4 but if it's attacked then
it can it can be a problem for white for
example if white goes King E3 if you
look into some line
which actually does not happen oh
because simplification is gonna Fabi
doesn't push kakash actually he's just
saying let's trade off pawns and is this
now just more or less a draw offer from
Fabi
looks that way I think so
now we're expecting the black Rook to go
and capture this Pawn on e4 it's hanging
why not and White's Rook is going to
most likely take this Black Sea Pawn
attacking the Black Knight but the Black
Knight will move and three versus three
on the same side symbolically maybe
slightly better for white but but I
believe that after rookie for white is
going to play King F3 or G3 and only
after that take on the pawn because if
after black takes the pawn and if white
takes Rook C2 then white black can take
with the check the F4 pawn and go back
to f8 to defend the Knight
yeah so actually this point is hanging
in wow we stay with this game for the
handshake it has happened and it's a
draw
a bit of a surprising end there but fair
result yeah and uh it is indeed a fair
result both players playing very well
and Fabi yesterday in the interview I
actually said I don't know why I'm not
getting armageddon's I like them well
his wish has been granted he will be
playing an Armageddon with the white
pieces he'll be in a must win situation
in approximately 20 minutes so don't
miss that one guys this will be a very
challenging match and I'm very much
looking forward go cash will be set his
mind and get ready with his coach around
for the next game where he knows that he
cannot lose in that case he scores the
maximum point out of the Armageddon
and let's head back to the bird's eye
view I mean you guys really got your
crystal ball out and predicted all the
correct moves against sir anishagiri and
Ari antari that's just as you said it
would be and uh
think the most interesting game is
Magnus Carlson against alireza farouza
should we dive back in there
sure
I mean it's not even a question I think
that that is so much action happening
and it's so interesting the bone
structure the bone sacrifice which was
done by Magnus the peace placement so
there are a lot to talk about that while
in the other games it's uh it's going on
their own path which we discussed
already yeah
and this is the position we see in front
of us Magnus with his last move has just
played rooked D1 so they've actually
only been a couple of moves since we
were last here we should also mention
farrugia's previous move Bishop to A6
cost him almost half an hour on the
clock nearly 30 minutes there thinking
on that one move and uh yeah after Rook
to D1 he's back in the tank uh this Rook
move looks mysterious Jude it but I
guess the idea is for white tonight to
maybe land on C4 over the next couple of
turns and The Rook on D1 might be opened
up later on against the black queen well
first of all uh probably white thought
that he doesn't want to leave that Rook
there so the question was whether Rook
B1 or Rook D1 and I I completely agree
that probably Knight C4 idea is what
Magnus has in mind but of course there
are a lot of options for white because
there are a lot of Temptation to play F5
or to play E5 to break that bone
structure and the D6 Pawn will have to
be deciding that they're capturing on E5
but in any case the C5 Pawn will be very
weak also maybe black sometimes would
have this idea if the Rook would not be
on D1 to play C4 sacrifice the pawn and
after that white captures to play C5 to
make some space for the Knight on C6 and
then enter to the D4 and I think this is
also why Magnus played Rook D1 that it's
a prophylactical move as well for black
the problem is I believe that it's very
hard to find a good plan
and every opening up the position
whether it's D5 E5 F5 or whatever the
black king we should not forget that in
the center it can get in trouble yeah
and I guess the big thing that alireza
is thinking about is what is White's
plan so you've mentioned quite a few of
them and if black has an adequate
response to all of those plans then I
guess alireza has a free move
but uh so say for instance black does a
DOT move I don't I don't know what let's
jump in and show what happens if black
does play yeah a bit of a stinker here
just a bit of a slow move uh Rook to B8
for example
okay and so say white plays Knight E5
okay E5 the most aggressive move and
creating a square for the Knight
undermining the C5 Pawn
I like it Judith this is quite typical
as well of this Pawn structure right
what is also interesting for example
after Rook B8 also I was thinking just
to play against your opponent because
this is also very important and
sometimes magnus's strengths is also
that to play A4 for example not even
think about Bishop B5 or Rook B5 and
sacrifice let's say on A5
and just an option I'm not sure it's the
best because I'm very much eager to play
E5 and break that bone structure of
black well it's actually been positively
encouraged by far Asia because uh he's
now reacted with F5
and this is desirable in general he's
kind of blocked off at least one of the
white porn pushes white can't push F5
also the black king we're talking about
safe havens the safest I can see at
least is F7 and uh maybe even G6 or
later on if the center really closes the
black king can at least hope now that
the f file is blocked to find a safe
square but it does as you mentioned
should it encourage white to step
forward now with E5 I don't know if you
need to rush maybe you can keep the
tension and move or two actually I like
F5 because it makes space for the king
and generally for black species and uh
and also I believe that maybe F5 was
also something to be worry at time to
time but uh yeah after F5 of course the
first idea I would be looking at is E5
still
though after E5
um maybe D takes E5 F takes E5 and queen
D5 yeah let's show this on the board is
there a direct problem with the
immediate E5 because it's desirable as
mentioned here unfortunately because of
how our King stands we don't really uh
want to take on C5 this looks very
strong but it is met by a check and the
Queens come off the board uh White's
anyway to save the Knight this is
undesirable you mentioned F takes E5
dude and our Queen to D5
hard to protect this Pawn suddenly is
there a way
yeah I mean could you step back with a
bishop Bishop that's one way how do you
step forward with the bishop Maybe also
67 I also saw that one as well there's
trying to kick back this queen later on
exactly and then you can also play in
like Knight C4 at the right time
C4
some juicy dark squares in the black
Camp to try and get to with the white
pieces later on
yeah so if E5 does happen maybe black
shouldn't uh release the tension maybe
black should just try and uh get the
king to safety before it's too late is
the king gonna hide itself on G6
yeah I would love to
I'm not sure why just aesthetically
quite nice maybe black should be going
next move King F7 on E5 yeah King F7
right
and maybe this is where magnus's plan
behind uh mysterious Rook move Knight C4
and suddenly there's some tension if
this Knight is eliminated at the very
least we'll regain this Pawn or this
Pawn let's say D5 due to the pin and now
notice C5 happens
you could maybe foresee this being a
logical sequence of moves favoring
weight perhaps but at least now we
justify the placement of this Rook
opposite the queen
yeah I think Magnus will play E5 I have
a feeling just I don't know how else to
improve the position I don't know I just
wanted to say that I'm not sure E5 will
be played maybe he wants to play King H1
for example just to forget about all
these kind of ideas where black uses the
D4 Square
taking something
but then maybe F takes E4 and then black
can forget about this problem forever
that white is going to play E5 yeah
there's a pin so we can't take with the
pawn which would be really nice and
desirable suddenly yeah as he said uh
maybe we can block things this Black
Knight or maybe we don't need to rush
with that one maybe there's a better
move Knight C5 yeah I just realized by
C5 I was tactically slow there hitting
the queen hitting the bishop and uh now
something's collapsing maybe 1966 the
reason we played King H1 have this many
four checks right yeah just to say that
in this position yeah there's nothing to
hit on G1 I walked right into that one
but yeah if as long as kind of we don't
allow Knight take C5 to happen this is a
beautiful Outpost for the Black Knight
later
on F5 still sharp you've got to think
very sharp I mean this is a really
interesting game going on between Magnus
and the alireza so after F5 it is a
question whether E5 immediately or can
white go Knight C4
yeah
also same theme justifying the fact this
Rook is on D1
I was wondering about taking here
which way you recapture it gets shot
this is what I was wondering
can't take with the pawn anymore you
have to defend your knight and if Queen
takes I was thinking some crazy things
but I don't even dare to save Yeah
question is whether D5 Works what's the
crazy thing
after Fe but I think that's going too
far oh tal would be impressed I think
that that's too far I was thinking that
takes takes and d e but Bishop D4 check
otherwise I would be after Queen B8
taking Knight C5 giving up the exchange
but I think this exchange sacrifice is
not that exchange sacrifice it's not the
same if you get the white square Bishop
of black or the black Square Bishop
yeah this one not quite working black
can plug the holes
oh let's give Magnus a bit of time to
ponder E5 it's a committal decision
but uh it's a big one
maybe he needs to go for it if he wants
to win this game
certainly looks that way it's very sharp
position there is one more question I
would ask from you what do you think
about C4
is it it's a very committed move is it a
good idea for white to kill the A6
Bishop
or not really
well A5 on the board our questions have
been answered yes and looking at my
computer screen it's being awarded an
exclamation mark
good move good move from Magnus also a
logical move uh maybe the most uh kind
of natural move in the position it just
depends on what Russia has up his sleeve
clock times really do not favor Black
right now that massive massive thing on
push Basics uh could come back to haunt
him later
but for now it's tense and maybe black
has some resources here yeah I mean all
the variations look so nice for white
though actually I have a question after
the E5 maybe Knight C5 right
so
maybe it's possible to take okay let's
win D4 Queen F2
let's jump in and show this
Ivanka you had some thoughts as well
yeah basically I will Enlighten you
later okay
not because I I cheated I thought this
is very complicated and I thought you
know what let's have a judge decide on
what is the best move so this this hit
this double attack you want to meet with
a block that's what I thought
makes any sense
and you take with I thought with the
king king you're hitting my Bishop
I'll try and save it Bishop C8 a bit of
a sad move but needs to be done
protecting this Pawn as well
and how do you continue it looks like
you've got some various night jumps that
could be quite tempting yeah Knight C4
Knight D6 is tempting but it's like only
check send me a check this game is
played for checkmate you take this Pawn
you could drop back with the bishop if
you want to maybe well maybe this is a
nice move for Bishop C3 yeah but Bishop
C3 Knight G6
mm-hmm now we re we wish our King was
back on G1
um
still tempting for weight the knights
are coming yeah this is a very
complicated Ivanka you need to reveal
there was a magical Point here magical
moment there why wow it was interesting
because I I peaked and the computer said
that there is only really one way for
black to avoid being significantly worse
and that's actually to put the Knight on
G6 this entire position current position
anything else and black will be a lot
worse like minus uh sorry plus one for
white
wow okay so the stakes are high black
needs to find Knight G6 Judith do you
feel that's natural will that be on
Furious radar
well there is not much of a choice you
know black has to be careful a lot
because these spawns can be very weak in
a second I mean Knight C4 is a huge
threat and this is my question that
after Knight G6 what happens on Knight
C4
good question uh important one I think
we have to show this because black might
have only one move to minimize the
damage oh and guess what he finds it oh
okay he finds it Knight G6 of course if
you give the top players in the world a
narrow path often they are great at
navigating that Andrew you mentioned
Knight C4 hitting this Pawn Yeah I'm
wondering what's going on after that
do I have to take you let's eliminate
this Knight
but this looks so scary I have to play
D5 here you can take my Pawn yeah this
is the question goes there Knight C5 and
then you go with Queen E7 or queen C8
I feel like the queen should travel on
light squares just so it doesn't get hit
some hits along the diagonal let's say
light squares Queen C8 Queen F7 which
one your Banker
C8 C8 yeah you want to sneak out with
your king yes
exactly on the light squares
you know
I have a word for this kind of King I
like to skedaddle out of there let's say
I'm off it still can't Castle we
shouldn't forget but the black king
hasn't lost castling rights yet probably
King on F7 stands better defending the
E6 spawn yep it looks like uh Checkers
pretty much just on light squares with
Plex uh Pawn chain uh Queen night King
all on light squares
fighting on that color complex but yeah
good spot from Russia yeah it's not so
easy but probably there is some other
way also for black maybe after Knight C4
I see four
is there anything else for black
struggling it feels like taking his
surely going to be too risky
D takes E5
actually I wouldn't touch that one with
the barge part although the evaluation
Bar says black is okay but um it looks
scary because suddenly white can take
this Pawn with the Knight where I can
just take back at the center but uh
black does have ideas there maybe
yeah because you still have a after
Knight takes C5 you still have this
queen D4 check up your sleeve yeah it's
double attack most common tactic in
chess yeah this is looking on G1 makes
all the treble
looks like fishing random chests but
yeah it's just white shuffled the pieces
on the wrong order on the first rank
that's just annoying and maybe if we
take the other way uh instead of Knight
65 maybe the idea is to just hmm take
this light off the board it looks really
ugly from a kind of aesthetic point of
view for black but if we just move
suddenly White's got some weaknesses
himself yeah and the E5 Pawn is under
attack and if you have to come back
Bishop C3 it's going to be slow finally
I can Castle
suddenly anything's still possible here
but it's not clear whose pieces are
better I like this black porn chain
suddenly yeah so let's go back to Knight
G6
what happens if white captures on D6
immediately
one takes Pawn
what could be more natural
and if I take back
what about Knight C4 that's one of my
questions
hit my queen
I will oh I can't move really I wanted
to play Queen D5 but now you can Retreat
maybe and you hit my queen and next move
if the queen Retreats back at night
there is a pin out of five
whoops
so if I can't play night uh sorry if I
can't play Queen D5 after Knight to C4
maybe it's something similar but an
improved version for white no you have
to go to Queen well or queen E7 you can
go or queen E7 immediately without
capturing
yep and then Queen E3 let's say
weaknesses these double pawns are just
so ugly often double pawns uh kind of we
Breeze past them but here's like the
epitome of uh weaknesses porn Islands
yep well it's a critical moment in that
game but we also have an Armageddon
Brewing it is between Fabiana caruana
and gukash and let's remind ourselves of
the Armageddon format white that's
Fabiano we'll start with 10 minutes
black will have seven minutes and there
will be a one second increment after
move 40 and this is the most important
thing black does have draw odds white
isn't a must-win situation and the
points will be like this one and a half
points for a win and 1.1 Armageddon loss
and the players now speeding up they're
playing into an anti-balen it's it's a
repeat of the line that they just played
yep we're off and totally repeating uh
exactly the variation that we saw
earlier in their classical encounter and
Fabi he's switching up the move order
Maybe
go cash the first to think he doesn't
have too much time he needs to react
very quickly here
some threats potentially against white
people uh Black Sea porn story in the
next few moves so black has to First
decide which side he wants to Castle on
the Black Knight goes back
and okay he drops back his Bishop Favi
armed he had this with black actually
yesterday against Abdul sotoro so an
expert on both Colors oh now there's a
question is Bishop B4 will be the move
or just uh yeah rugby Queen C8 Queen C8
is that on the board yeah this Knight
looks offside misplaced but it is tying
down Black's Queen to this B7 pawn and
the B7 Pawn cannot move because the C6
Pawn would drop so B3 really slow
playing it here from Fabi uh that's one
strategy and Armageddon just just keep
pieces on the board make sure there are
no portraits and try to flag the
opponent later yeah and you put pressure
on the opponent you try to make him
think to decide some things but it's
very slow
very slow and it's a very effective
strategy when uh the in the Armageddon
games and white has five minutes and
black has four
especially online chess but anyway good
cash stepping forward with the c Pawn
this is what white wants when he goes to
Knight C5 because B6 was not possible
because of Knight C6 so white black push
C5 so in the next move he wants to push
away the Knight I believe yeah this is
really bad news for the Blackfish one E7
which is kind of entrapped now behind
its own pawns but at the same time Black
Rock Solid no Pawn breaks for white
Insight yet and first decision for Fabi
is he really thinking about jumping into
C6 it looks like the automatic move is
to retreat suicide
yeah you've got to keep your note
protected
and he did so now he's moving the other
direction he's kind of uh done the odd
Switcheroo pushed black on the queen
side and suddenly switched the attention
to the king side now F5 in the air also
some Pawn breaks for the first time with
F4 later on so interesting that how is
it possible I mean I was always having
difficulties to understand that look the
pawn on C5 for some reason it limits
much more Black's opportunities to play
these positions than if the poem would
be on C6 right so white even lost two
tempies in order to force black to play
C5 this I found always very interesting
in this system
and I've always loved this Pawn chain
it's white it's the it's the V just kind
of protecting in both directions from C2
to E4 and C2 to A4 but of course that
means uh you're solid but yeah no breaks
on that side the queen side essentially
closed for the next few moves Fabi needs
to go for the black king there we go
Queen F3 oh black mate space for one of
his pieces for f8 I don't know if Knight
f8 will come most likely the bishop will
be oh Knight B8 the Knight retreating to
its starting Square getting ready to
jump to C6 and D4
yup a great route for that black knight
into the center kokesh looking up there
to check how many moves they've made
there seems to be a habit just maybe a
nervous uh kind of nervous reaction from
the players it's only moved 16 he's not
getting any increment anytime soon but
yeah nice undeveloping move retreating
move there gotta go back to come forward
taking advantage of the fact that he had
to play C5 right so now there is a place
for the night on C6 and going into D4
yeah and right now breaking out with F4
trying to open some lines and blacks
Knight jumping in big threat on the
board which it's reacted with Rook F2
Fabby blocks everything there
and uh just quickly our reporter svara
caught up with Fabiano right before this
Armageddon game so let's have a quick
listen to what Fabiano had to say
this half point is looking to become
pretty important for the tournament
situation any special plans for are you
gonna attack this game well I guess
we'll see in a few minutes I don't know
it's Armageddon it should be exciting
um I haven't played one since uh against
Hanish it's been a while that I haven't
played Norm again so hopefully it'll be
fun these armageddons do you feel like
it's a coin flip or do you feel like the
better player most often goes out
Victorious I think the better player
usually wins but it's also a coin flip
because many of the players here are
pretty evenly matched thank you thanks
mm-hmm
and there we have Fabiano promising us
excitement and indeed it is super
exciting now as Fabiano has taken
control of the center
and temporarily white is a pawn up we
saw a question mark appear briefly on
the board when black put the king in the
corner and okay recapturing Bishop H6
whoa Judith tactically sharp White Queen
cannot move because this Knight is hit
by the black bishop and you want to play
Bishop H6 the threatening Checkmate oh
he doesn't go for that instead Knight F5
still going for checkmate trying to
force the knights off the board
should we investigate that well should
we say H6 last move Bishop F6 on the
board well this is this is also very
tempting for a white that's clear
you could still do Bishop H6
it's not the same it certainly isn't
we got the bishop 86 so you can take and
after Knight takes Rook f8 because the
E5 Pawn is protected right yeah black
can defend everything just in time he's
looking at tactics like this I would be
very inclined to play a move like Bishop
G5 just to kind of eliminate this black
Defender the black Bishop's a bit sad
but it holds everything together for now
okay Fabi he's paused really slowed down
sensing an opportunity the top players
they sense these critical moments
you'll move on the board the Bishops are
gonna get traded big threat against the
G7 Pawn that's why it could cash stepped
forward with the queen but Fabi has an
easy position to play it's just simply
to line up on the F line and see what
happens with those Rooks
it's a very promising position for white
so much tension now on the f file he's
going to be looking for tactical blows
Black's isolated E Pawn is a big factor
in the position right now some ways to
attack that
what to go for now it looks like
everything's perfectly set up E7 also
sometimes can be very
damn thing I was looking at that but
then I also got tempted just by the calm
move as well you can just drop your
knight back and then jump in with the
Knight to D5 but okay we have a safety
first move from Carolina getting his
King out of any potential trouble
yeah it feels a bit slow however and if
gokash can survive eventually in the end
game he'll have good chances it feels
like white needs to deliver a knockout
while Queen's and Rooks remain on the
board don't forget that white also has a
weak weak a pawn later in the game uh
first what to do with this White Queen I
really like the move Knight D6 it's a
good Defender and if after Queen G3
black would be going Knight F4 blocking
the Rooks on the F5
yeah Knight F4 beautiful post for the
night as long as white cannot evict it
with a pawn so maybe another another
square with the White Queen no he does
drop back to G3
your moves on the board there Judith the
Black Knight is holding things together
for kukesh
he's really sped up you've got to say
and queen G4 now getting ready again G3
kicked this Knight out what about G6
mirroring this same idea G6 kicking the
White Knight out first but black still
has problems with the E5 Pawn so any end
game will also be very double-edged on
account of that and instead gukesh also
preparing to line up his Rooks or
potentially use his Rook to attack the
White Queen
yeah Fabi has to kick that black knight
now that's the whole point of his play
kukesh I've got to say defending really
well he had a difficult position
it looked like everything was falling
apart but suddenly very difficult to
play it with the black side I believe
he's doing a good job though 3 minute 40
against just under five minutes for Fabi
and Knight to E3 retreating this is your
point Ivanka if the queen trade happens
on White's terms then the White Knight
repeats uh and kind of replaces this uh
White Queen on G4 and the black E5 Pawn
would be doomed so quintix Queen offs
the table and the idea for white if
there is no exchange then probably G3
can be the move and Knight plays to D5
but now the e390s attack
counter-attacked by angukash
preventing white from jumping in with
the Knight to D5 because of tactical
reasons
it's
interesting interesting idea I mean I'm
presumably
white was a step forward and defined
that night
I believe that maybe white will decide
to go back because if Rook F3 for
example then The Rook on F6 on the sixth
rank it can be chasing the queen in that
case Rook G6 Rook H6 Rook F6 pushing the
right Queen back
of course Fabiano is in a must-win
situation A draw is completely
insufficient insufficient insufficient
yeah he needs to just repeat just go
back fabi's really slowed down his three
minute time Advantage at the start of
this Armageddon has dwindled down to one
minute less than a minute now and okay
second time we've seen this position and
he changes it up does play G3 as
predicted Judith now the Black Knight
has to make a decision
going back as well and white tonight the
superior of the two but still no
breakthrough still lacking a direct plan
well black improved his position
significantly I think G3 is something
that maybe white was not so comfortable
having that bone you don't have tactics
possibilities like for instance Knight
takes
Pawn on G7 on G7 is not quite working
out is it we're actually six maybe is uh
always on the cards here blacks are
sliding across
oh okay he hesitates Fabby there but
does step back with his Knight offering
a rook trade to take her not to take
Judah to take
those Rooks off the board
quickly as possible I think the take is
better because otherwise if Rook moves
away Queen H5 and the E5 Pawn is in
danger
just mulling over his options here we're
expecting him to try and take as many
Rooks off the board as possible long
term black is okay which short-term
needs to survive this wave or the other
idea is to play doubling The Rook on f8
and then getting ready to have an F6
spawn but I'm not sure it looks like it
can be vulnerable
yeah and I agree in the feature chat
Fabi has been burning a lot of time but
suddenly go cash on this one move has
slowed down
40 seconds and counting because it's a
critical moment how to exchange the
Rooks in what circumstances
and on Whose terms uh you're right
what's he gonna do he does go for that
latter option you mentioned all the
Rooks disappearing from the board but
black has a very weak backward F Pawn
now
can Fabi attack that one he's in the
move he's got the time to strike with
the initiative
oh it feels like it's on the edge for
black here well Knight on E6 stands
extremely well defending the C7 pawn and
black wants to defend F6 playing Queen
F7 and King G7 but Fabiana of course he
does it very very
in with slideland
moves
Silent Assassin Fabiana caruana silent
but deadly here Queen F7 yeah and I like
how he's just taking away some squares
from the Black Knight now the White
Knight is likely to come in sooner or
later yeah
but I feel that good cash has been very
crafty with his last move he's gotten
out of the pin and getting ready to jump
forward with his own Knight into the
Santa
if I'm so far he's doing a pretty good
job managing his time he's nearly one
minute behind but he's still handling it
well now the question is H5 is it a good
move or it's too dangerous
kick away that White Queen gain space
gains time but maybe a weakness long
term
a big decision and not an easy one to
make in Armageddon chess Fabi just
moving his King is he going on a king
walk all the way to the queen side maybe
that's a good journey
to start with
and apparently a missed opportunity for
Fabiano there but still looks like white
has the advantage and it says static
Advantage it's going to endure for a
long long time here
okay Queen trade to trade or not to
trade not to trade that's for sure you
cannot trade the Queens unless he's
winning a pawn immediately
yeah white screen more active than its
counterpart normally that's a good
indicator of whether to take pieces off
the board
well now the question is will Knight D4
impossible but then Queen C8 Queen G7 C3
and white knight shows up on F5 that can
be dangerous yeah it's too scary to
allow the white pieces in and wow H5
giving the Black Knight more squares but
he wants to plant that pawn on the H6
Square trapping the black king this is
the reason I was hesitating to play H5
with black
big big questions now for good cash to
answer and only one minute to do so he
blocks the advance of whites H Pawn huge
weakness on G6 now white wants to have
replacement now made space for the
Knight on F5
that white knight is coming but Knight
G7 can be
something to to look for the H5 bone
enough to check black was getting E8
something I think he has to allow the
White Queen in behind butkukesh it's a
scary decision to make only 50 seconds
yeah and he steps up with the King he
just has to hold this position if he
wants to walk away with an Armageddon
Victory and it's looking like Fabiano is
in full control both on the clock and on
the board at the same time gokish is not
giving easily his skin
well Fabby jumping forward with his
Knight is now the time for gokash to
offer a night trade that's a big
question to offer it and from where on
the Knight D4 or to Knight G7
get rid of that white knight by any
means possible and Judith says it yeah
two moves to do so he's got to choose
he's got to just trust his instincts
here under 30 seconds before I think
Knight D6 can be a dangerous
continuation for weight and a big shout
out to Robert Hess hello Fabi is playing
this game extremely well
yeah extremely calmly just full control
never panicking slowly improving his
position I totally agree and 97 given a
question mark by the computer but why it
looks solid it looks like he's forcing
the nitrate White's H5 Pawn also
vulnerable
cash under 20 seconds but he will be
getting that one second move increment
and Fabiano giving a few checks just to
build up some time on the clock and look
at that the C6 Pawn Has Fallen
yeah he's pulling up now and Dwight does
have the option of trading queens in a
lot of positions to convert his
Advantage this is going to be a tough
end game only 16 seconds for a good
crash it does not look good for him
because the King march is going to be
going all the way to F5 eventually but
look at Fabiano he just improves the
position of his Queen and as David
highlighted that King march is very much
on the board okay good cash attacking
the H5 Pawn
and the King march you predicted that
Judah it's happening and it transpires
that actually black has no tracks here
you just have to wait because so passive
that's been the story of the game so far
black just on the defensive it's about
whether Fabi can continue marching in
later on first the white king is tied
down to the defense of this H porn you
need to finesse it a bit how to do so
okay side steps any checks very logical
stuff and he needs a breakthrough still
no passports for white that's uh maybe
the next step yeah and a good cash just
four seconds left on the clock
and another question mark for this black
move it looks very natural it's nothing
good to be done here as black how's Fabi
gonna finish this I'll put A5 can be a
strong move here because black cannot
take on A5 to Queen C5 and the fight can
push the pawn all the way to A6 that
would lead to complete win yeah I think
biting his time Fabi he'll change the
position he'll go for this a pawn push
when he's 100 sure but first Sunday is
black attacking the eighth one no
because there's a queen check on G6 yeah
black Force to sit and wait
uh is actually going to do a king walk
on the other side of the board move it
all the way to the A-line and then
prepare this A5 idea
just got full control this is a
beautiful Square for the White Queen the
black queen can barely move
and he's just going to defend everything
and infiltrate via the queen side with
his King practically there is no way
that go cash can escape with such a
small time on his clock for seconds but
look at that B6 A5 was played oh he's on
a three seconds he's playing as quickly
it's a human can something very close to
the squares to each other
trying to build a fortress kukash but
suddenly counter play he's going active
with the black queen Fabi has to be
really careful the black queen cannot
sneak behind now and develop deliver
some checks fabby's winning all the
Pawns in the meantime what kind of
drawing opportunity
yeah if black gets one move and give
some checks the white king might not
Escape how will white win
s
lost on time
that was unexpected it came from nowhere
but in the end it was good cash who
survived and managed to net those one
and a half points and the chat just sums
it up that oh my God
wow what a game well I think when we go
down under 10 seconds with only one
second bottles this generous bonus time
per move I mean at that point if you
just lose your focus and concentration
for second or two then this is what can
happen yeah and uh well I think this is
a perfect time for us to catch our
breaths and take a break so see you all
in a few minutes
do you wish playing a chess game with a
friend was as easy as sending them a
text well good news now it is but
chess.com's new iMessage app you can
start and play a game directly in
iMessage your friend doesn't even need a
chest.com account it's just tap and play
head over to go.chess.com iMessage or
use the command iMessage in chat to
learn more
chess kit is fun chess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent-approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational
the kids it feels just like playing the
chest is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking chess kid
features a comprehensive training
program that guides kids to level up on
their way to Mastery there are more than
fifty thousand chess vessels and a whole
library of entertaining videos that
teach strategies tactics openings and
end games specifically for kids
chess kit is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds signing up is free and easy so
what are you waiting for
[Music]
I remember that day it was Unreal I
definitely felt like I was walking on
air
yeah it was like such a beautiful
feeling because I won the the first
championship that was actually combining
women and men into the same section so
in addition to winning the title and the
money which I really needed it was like
something like 9 500 but I was like a
college student at the time and like
literally that was like all the money I
had in my bank account after cashing
that check
so that was really cool and then also I
kind of I have Norm so it was like a
little bit of everything
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
hello and welcome back oh what an
exciting Armageddon we had there and we
are very lucky to have here in the
studio kakash who actually defeated
Fabiana Karana in perhaps one of the
wildest armageddon's I've seen in a long
time uh wow
um so talk us through the whole match
um yeah
um the classical game I think it was
quite uh
uh it was just good prep and I got a i
equalized quite easily uh with
after the opening and uh
okay he was trying for some chances in
the end game but okay I think I was
accurate enough with Knight C8 and yeah
it was just a draw and uh
um after that Armageddon yeah he uh he
deviated from the classical game with H3
yeah and uh
yeah I was not not I could not remember
what to do and I got a bit of unpleasant
position especially in this time control
where there is no like clear plan and I
just move more on basis and
yeah he after that he got everything he
could have hoped for and of course I was
completely lost but uh
which was sorry which was the point
where you you thought that things may go
wrong
downhill
already uh
can we look at them
ah yeah
yeah already here I was kind of worried
because uh okay his plan is super clear
and
I can get my knight to defer but then he
has Rook F2 and I have to make sure that
I don't allow Knight F5 and
C7 is kind of weak so I have already
here I was a bit worried
and uh yeah I I did not react well from
here I think I got a very bad position
and
uh yeah and in the end uh
we were thinking about Bishop H6 here
yeah I saw Bishop H6 actually but I I
think he didn't spot it Bishop had six
uh
maybe I have to go to G8
but then uh
oh wait there's Knight E2 whoops oops
yeah sorry
but uh
yeah okay he can go Bishop G5 Bishop G5
Queen G5 rookie Rook F1 yeah similar
yeah I know rookie Rook F7 is there so
I have to go Queen E6 and rookie F1
similar to the game yeah it's very
anyways very unpleasant
and uh this queen end game were you
confident of holding it when the clocks
were ticking down
um no I thought I was lost but uh okay I
had like two possible moves so I was
playing uh playing it and just hoping
for something
and uh yeah when it came down to 10
seconds I thought I might have have a
chance because I from a long distance
from already at this point I spotted
that Queen A1 might be just a Perpetual
so I was trying to get it done yeah he
didn't spot it on time I think
and uh yeah okay he can take on B6 now
that I see it but uh in which position
instead of Queen is on just Queen Basics
so that after uh
ah it's still not clear
Empress
escaping so
yeah but it was so logical for him to
take the F6 Pawn with all these checks
and
he could still take
[Music]
okay he can go Queenie at queen j6 queen
F6 take on B6 and okay and it's that's
all but uh apparently this position is
still a draw though oh suddenly a draw
to Queen A1 yeah I had supported this
queen A1 Center but
yeah it's difficult under time pressure
right yeah but it's incredible that you
actually saw this resource so quickly
and with like literally seconds on the
clock no because like when I was playing
this queen of son Queen I had already
spotted when he started the king work
that I already spotted that I somehow if
I get my queen to A1 it's a draw I mean
it might be a draw so so hope is a plan
that's fascinating switching from kind
of passive defense like it's hard to get
out of that mindset and then suddenly
going on the kind of going active it's
yeah yeah it's always important right
well uh let's go back to the bird's eye
view and uh well just your quick
thoughts on some of the remaining games
especially the game between Magnus
Carlson and elareza farouza yeah
earthquake interested in this game
actually because Magnus played three
Bishop D3 and it was a completely random
position and Nelly razor just went for
G5 and we got an exciting position
and I guess now
okay
first first thought is virus what should
be really better
how confident are you because we had
hikara in hikara said absolutely 100 it
was only I paraphrased but you know you
get my gist white will win if I don't
see the evaluation bar I would say white
is just clearly winning but okay
I I don't know what is the resource that
black has no I think uh well we do see
the question mark in front of us with
the queen C3 White's last move and
apparently yeah this isn't me don't
worry I I have this under the coverage
nice one wow C5 suddenly there's a
threat of Queen takes Bishop because
okay that's really nice yeah yeah Magnus
has put his Queen on just a vulnerable
Square for example Knight takes Pawn
impossible now due to Queen takes Bishop
so it might have been important to Queen
B4 instead of Queen C3 yeah yeah I think
you're right uh Queen B4 or just any
uh safe square and big big Advantage for
white
okay Queen City is just a blunder I
think do you think alireza will find
this you know these guys really well
after Queen C3
will he spot C5 you can never say but if
someone have to pick to choose uh find
this movie it would be a little red so
you would find it also in a second
you did it just now but I think
hopefully when you have such an awful
position with black you're fine so
you're fine yeah and there we can see
the current leaderboard Coronas are 14
and a half points but you're there in
third place with 10 points how are you
going to approach the remaining two
rounds
um
I'll I'll try to play good chess I've
been playing good chess I think
but okay I didn't get many wins but uh
yeah if I keep playing good just I guess
the events will come at some point and
any plans for the rest day tomorrow
um not really uh
maybe some work as usual okay
I have to ask you've had five
armageddons you've won four of them and
you were so close to beating Magnus as
well uh do you have any tips Secrets how
you've become so good at that time
control that format
um not not very sure
I've played a lot of Armageddon actually
um
actually the
the only Armageddon I remember I lost
was
against uh Anton
jugaro in one of the Championship story
events
but I guess I've I've had a very good
record in Armageddon so maybe it's just
the confidence yeah
well confidence it certainly does
provide ELO points and it brings you
luck because you're always positive
about your position but I have to thank
you good cash for your time and for
coming to visit us in the studio and
Well Done once more on defeating Fabiana
caruana so and enjoy your free day
tomorrow yeah thank you thanks good luck
thank you
wow
that was an interesting moment there
when we actually managed to get the
thoughts of gukesh and were you also
impressed by how quickly kukash spotted
that C5 resource yeah absolutely and I
have the feeling that Magnus spotted it
as well
oh he knows it and and now he's thinking
you think body language giving it away
here I don't know he stood up and left
the board and then he came back but I
have the feeling that he spotted it
immediately
and I think we have to talk about the
Contours of this position as well uh
asukesh mentioned if White had gone for
any other move not allowing this
breakout with this trick with C5 then it
would have been full control even if uh
Black Winter Pawn on the C4 Square it's
not going to uh help it's not going to
solve all the problems why tonight it's
just gonna have a beautiful square a
beautiful outpost on C5 White's Bishop
is already entrenched in the black
position it's just a glorious kind of
dominance here unless this C5 move is
found and it's so interesting that
there's such a position many times the
relief can come only if material is
sacrificed and then wow lies for The
Rook because now there is no place for
The Rook right B8 is covered by the
bishop and there is no space for The
Rook but suddenly after F5 he misses it
it doesn't spot it wow
huge mess by for Asia it is difficult to
kind of spot these one-off tactical
shots when things suddenly change
unexpectedly but and huge relief for
Magnus yeah he needed to find it it's
just one of those positions we'll have
to ask him after the game because I'm
not quite sure that Magnus spotted this
resource because it's you know you're
putting your piece on priests those
moves are very difficult to see
I would bet that that Magnus saw it
immediately what about you you know him
very well yeah I think Magnus would have
seen it for sure no no the question is
did he see it now during the game oh yes
I think he after he's played Queen C3
that's my you think yeah yeah body
language it's as if he was trying to
keep a straight face trying he says I'm
leaving the board I don't show
that is classical chess wisdom if
something's changed if you realize
you've blundered just don't do anything
different don't kind of uh allow your
opponent to get out of is this the
reason he plays poker to practice maybe
he's been bluffing a bit this tournament
and now actually for Russia found a
similar idea black was threatening to
take this bishop on D6 due to this uh
pin along the diagonal but Magnus of
course ends that idea you play C5 look
how fast he played C5 he thought C5 you
will never ever play C5 in this game
over you had we have one chance one time
chance no way well it makes a lot of
sense right you cement that Bishop onto
D6 no one is ever getting that piece out
then the Knight will come to D4 and it's
going to be paradise along the B line
only now Magnus leaves the board once he
survived that nervous moment uh as you
say Ivanka Knight D4 this is like a
granite statue built in honor of the
bishop it's just controlling everything
it controls the whole game and yeah the
arrival of the night like you said rugby
one coming
black is stuck unable to fight here it's
going to be slow but uh certain
basically we can say that white is
winning strategically
and okay one more threat there for you
need some counter play he hits this
white Pawn he's banking on the fact that
white might play a move like G3 and
black can hope to open the H file later
on but maybe Magnus doesn't need to
even if he does takes an eternity for
black to arrange any kicking side
counterplay no space to shuffle yeah I
mean the queen on A6 also stands very
sad very far away from the king's side
and it's it cannot do too much anyway
yeah we should also mention if you ever
take this Pawn on A2 you will get
trapped the white Rook will simply slide
across and uh meanwhile we do have a
result from Wesley so and nordebec
abdusotoff it's been in the pipeline for
many hours now but Wesley so did beat
Nordic Abdul satorf to collect an
important three points
yeah
it's a tour of it's been a tough couple
of days a few losses now and Wesley
taking a win just jumping on the
mistakes feels like Abdul's toroff was
too ambitious in the opening and it
backfired but but what happened to
Nordic because you know he started off
with a bang you know he won the blitz
tournament and it looked like he was
going to be riding High and
the tournament just hasn't worked out
well for him yesterday he kind of
self-emploaded against Fabiano Carana
you know he just took risks which were
completely unnecessary
yeah it seems like he has a difficult
tournament now towards then maybe he's
also getting tired and he somehow does
not feel the uh how he should be playing
I mean today it's very clear that he had
a very bad opening choice because
practically I think it was moved 12 for
13 where he was having problems already
and it's not only that his position was
worse but he didn't have really any
consci chances and that's really painful
to play that way that you have a bad
opening and after that practically
you're just sitting and waiting that
your opponent is converting his
Advantage into Victory and it was so
much of of Wesley so style how to play
very slowly he's not in a rush he's
going to be make it slowly and it's just
so painful to sit there on the other
side yeah
well it was an important victory for
Wesley who now with those three points
will just go March up the standings
and there are two classical games
remaining
this one by Magnus Carlsen and also the
game against Anish and Ariane
shall we take a quick peek at that uh
other game and see what's happening
there
and if we were talking about this I was
mentioning it what happens if there is
four pawns versus three and having the
four Rooks on the board and what is very
interesting is that black has the double
pawns on the F5 right and the question
is whether is it better for black to
have these double pawns or would it be
better to have it on G6 because
sometimes the double F bones is not
bringing so much pain for black and for
defensive ideas actually it can work
pretty well yeah I think you're
completely right Judith from my
experience at least with single Rook end
games for example if it was just one
pair of Rooks actually having the double
F pawns makes it far easier to draw you
don't even have to think white cannot
create a passport it takes too long for
white to ever kind of push pawns forward
and trade off these two F pawns but with
double drugs more open lines towards the
black king maybe some Avenues of attack
maybe more targets for the white pieces
kind of with that in mind Iran would
love to just play a move like Rook
before and force the trade if uh Anish
could not resist that if he could not
find a way to avoid The Rook Exchange
but uh yeah for now with both Rooks on
the boards feels like more chances I I
think that there should be some chances
for White having both Rooks or four
books on Rooks on the on the board let's
say why it goes Rook D4
shall we jump in and show some potential
ideas root D4 what's the plan Judah well
I have several plans of course Rook D7
would be great for vine to double The
Rook on the sevens but for the moment
Rook B7 would be there
and the other plan is to go double The
Rook on the 8th rank so to go Rook G8
and somehow go after the seven F7 Pawn
but I'm not sure first of all that I can
get there and even if I get there if it
it can be something serious to bother
black skin and position well one thing
that immediately Springs out to me about
this idea is that white does have a safe
place for the king to hide so I'm
thinking if if white somehow manages to
double the works on the eighth line and
put a Pawn on F4 and a king on F3
the king is very safe
yeah but this is a big question whether
white will be able to to do this with
the safe circumstances because probably
black can go for example Rook A6 and
later on when the white root goes to the
eighth rank then trying to look for
counter chance doubling the black Rooks
on the second rank so black will always
look for counter chances at the same
time now rookie G8 King H6 Rook C4 can
be very unpleasant for black
or at least it looks scary because if
let's say black goes Rook F5 looking for
counter chances on F2 right would be
going Rook H4 check Rook H5 and then
white can exchange on H5 and after Rook
G7 white collects one more point one
more pawn and with that point as well
I think maybe the thing that's making a
niche pause right now is if we go back
to the current position a move like root
D4 he's going to go for the Perpetual
Chase of one of the white Rooks I think
that's why he's aligned his Rooks uh
like this ariantari really cleverly on
B6 and B5 for example he can drop back
say to this Rook where are you going if
the white Rook wants the seventh rank
he'll say okay where are you going and
uh he'll follow until the Rook has to
pretty much use the C4 square but then
Rook G4 would be possible to play after
Rook B8 and then you cannot pull your
Rook to G5 to stop the check but you
have to go to H6 and then already I can
come back with the Rook maybe to C4 and
your king is on this side so can I have
something over there this is true maybe
some chances I was hoping that I could
block with Rook G5 but then I will no
longer be able to chase you later but
maybe this is the reason why uh Anish
played Rook G4 checks so if black plays
Rook G5 only after that to play Rook D4
and then nothing can stop right from
playing group DX yeah so these moves on
the board as you say Judith now breaking
the connection Rook D4 and no way to try
and threaten The Rook trade still looks
promising one Rook trade is the big
difference here between a potential win
for a niche and a draw but okay Rook a
four instead same idea he's going behind
and he'll still pose huge problems for
any uh for Aryan let's see what happens
if Rook B2
yeah it was important to go Rook B2
because if you go Rook F5 F4 my idea
yeah yeah that's a good idea I think
so Rook B2
and the big question is does white have
time black is threatening now to go for
this Pawn
still not easy
still not straightforward it's not
one-way traffic
hmm
this is annoying this planet of counter
play
maybe it's time to go back we're careful
and just go play E4 what do you think
about E4 yeah
breaking the structure but because after
E4 you cannot go with the Rook anywhere
where you can double on the second rank
this is important and maybe this is why
he went to A4 look at the clever move
because if the Rook would be on the Ford
and black would play Rook A5 and double
on the second rank what if
fine move
this is the idea yeah just a shot on the
board now blackstroke has an extra file
with which to sneak around the back
that's in the game yeah if I wouldn't
need the idea rugby two E4 and this
black Rook is controlled he's
sophisticated and he's really classy in
life and in the in end games clearly
yeah still difficult and suddenly mating
ideas as he pointed out Ivanka uh later
on against the black king so what
happens if after Rook A4 Black Goes Rook
D5
so I also try to be clever
but now you've had to spend a move on
Rook D5 it takes you two moves to attack
the F Pawn maybe I can go behind now
um
but I didn't waste the time that's what
you want to say oh this black Rook has
wasted a bit of time and they're okay
four
and lawnmower chocolate yeah
wow actually the price of one move the
price of one tempo might be extremely
high here I love this Rook A4
yeah it looks like everything's the same
but there's always a difference right
there's always an idea behind these top
players moves
and this would be deadly for black yeah
to play but I have to say it's also very
principled as well because generally you
do want to put your Rooks far away give
yourself maximum checking distance
so okay I have one more question I'm
resisting so what about Rook F5
okay Rook F5 let's show this or you just
go E4 no on the E4 rookie five okay E4
yeah rookie five now maybe ivanka's idea
is that too brave Ivanka wanted to play
F4 immediately instead of E4 yeah but
it's okay look the bar went up
I can take credit
are good
right now
and let's say Black's Rook moves uh
where do I go B7 okay let's say go back
to E7
what to do next why is the engine loving
white so much in this maybe white wants
to go King F3 and again a nice Journey
with the King all the way to H5 let's
just give Checkmate video
[Laughter]
anybody stop me
no no no I'm gonna let it happen
I was sure you're on my side
yeah
Unstoppable Checkmate incoming we can
say that for now uh yeah let's maybe
take a pause from this game because it
looks like severe issues for ariantari
in his quest to draw as black
not easy at all to hold this end game
and he's also going down in time so
that's extremely stressful very
difficult I think to defend this
position
talking about going down in time take a
look at alirez's clock he's now down to
11 and a half minutes he has let's move
26 so he has like 14 moves left
but trust me the time is absolutely
secondary problem there for black is
just an extra if I may say
yeah this one it I mean white has
Connect Four if you look at the white
porn chain from H2 to E5 it's like
Connect Four topped off by a king or
like a big boss at the uh D6 Square it's
just full control this Black Knight is
caged stuck inside the pawn chain this
black Bishop is totally caged as well
how do you ever eliminate this white
Bishop you simply cannot it will be
replaced by another Pawn connect five if
uh if you ever capture it later with
your Bishop all night actually it's so
interesting that firoza missed his
opportunity with C5
and the reason I think he missed it
because he simply had for such a long
time a bad position that he did not
believe it anymore that he will get any
chance against Magnus to recover
otherwise if he wouldn't have suffered
for so long before probably he would
have found found it but still I'm
extremely surprised
yeah I'm desperately trying to think of
something for alireza to do let's maybe
ask what the Breakthrough is let's say I
just put a rook on B7 how is white going
to break through here
starts with The Rook B1 I don't mind to
exchange
if I could magically teleport this Rook
to the B file I'd be happy by the way
Queen D3 is also possible that would be
some winning material limited right oh
wow Queen to D3
I mean look at the C6 and E6 pawns they
are so vulnerable and you cannot defend
it with the
anything yeah
phone's dropping The Rook can always
swing come in yeah okay three okay six
Queen D3 that's a huge threat and
did we just have a move yeah he's just
moved Rook F7 okay but that surely
doesn't change too much Rook F7 is the
game position well Queen D3 even in this
position it just uh good work
immediately black could go Queen A4
well there's so many tempting moves
it's very hard to ruin it with white
feels like we might trap this queen at
some point even or B1 yeah Ruby one
would be three to K3 right yeah but the
evaluation boss having a field day here
going up and down it's always ending up
on white side quite significantly this
is a winning position for white as uh
Judith mentioned strategically it's just
whether black can land a trick well
there is a trick for example if Rook B3
and after that Rook fb1 comes then
Bishop F4 right it's one of the nasty
tricks black would be saving uh
let's say Bishop takes F4 yeah just to
show this tactic and suddenly
Queen takes D4 whoops it was probably
this is the only trick in the in the
position there's no other trick I'm
feeling back
he's literally waving it it's got the
signpost in that direction I mean
there's no way that Magnus is not going
to take it's not gonna allow this
basically that bar was bizarre
the way all the way yeah Rook F7 it's a
bit of a sad move I'm trying to figure
out what the idea is I mean every move
is as sad as each other right now I
guess well basically it made space but
for which piece that's the maybe a night
coming to D7
but then again this then there would be
no trick exactly
well I think eventually he wants to play
H4
and and maybe to put his Rooks to the H
file but it it should be very slow
you know why he played Rook F7 I tell
you because after Queen D3 Queen A4 if
the Rook is not on F7 then Knight E6
would be a killer so let's see if there
would be H4 in the previous move
let's put this on the board quickly yeah
if uh yeah if black hadn't gone this
Magnus has just played Rook D1 if black
had played for example yeah uh let's say
Bishop G7 then Queen D3 and if the black
queen Dodges the trade boom Judith yeah
you're right Queen takes F5 yeah I think
uh
so this is why he played Rook F7
but unfortunately for uh alireza farouja
here still reacting still passive
totally totally stuck and after Rook V1
H4 is on the board finally as you
mentioned Judith but counterplay a
distant dream
well it is looking like it's gonna be a
miserable day for farrugia as he suffers
on the position
but
we are very lucky to have here in the
studio
joining us very shortly it's a
he's just getting ready
we'll be there soon we are very lucky to
have here with us in the studio Wesley
so yeah very very lucky to
get the win but I'm very glad to join
you guys have fun yeah good to see you
David here
I'm a favorite breath player performance
to the left Olympia uh thank you
thanks for the question
it's going to be in Budapest but
probably it's um it's not the secret if
I say that most likely I will not get
back
yeah I just remember uh two months ago
with her playing some of her games from
the old informator back when we are
number seven in the world
thanks for reminding me for that
so Wesley you just beat um
that's okay yeah no I was just gonna say
you just beat nordeback Abdi satoroff I
mean talk us through that game yeah I
think with a very interesting game well
he played the Queen's Gambit accepted
which everyone seems to
go for now because it's a very simple
opening you can play it on move two and
uh if white doesn't play Third move E4
black it's a very solid position so the
lines are very limited but he surprised
me in the opening by playing Queen F6
which gives a very risky line but um
it's always difficult when you're
playing against the computer on the
board so I totally maybe I checked this
once in my life a year ago but well the
main line for Queen F6 is Bishop E6
and then here
Bishop E6 and then here I've won the
critical life is Knight bd2 and then
black has to play Queen F6
and then gas along like when I fix is
the only move here
so that's what I was expecting
but he played Queen F6 right away which
uh surprising because I can still move
my C1 Bishop I thought this lines pretty
dubious like uh I thought that will
Bishop g5.9 G5 fold by F4 also looks
very interesting
but I didn't really wanna
test his preparation
okay maybe it's a bad move but looks
very interesting over the board
if I just played normally with Bishop G5
so you're already out of prep by this
point or you have had some idea what to
do I thought I I look at it one thing my
entire career maybe a year ago so how is
it how you deal with such a situation
when a youngster comes up makes a move
new move and move six or seven and how
do you react what kind of fears you have
that okay it's all prep with engines so
how do you escape from that yeah so it's
not easy but A good rule of thumb I
guess is
uh played the the most logical moves the
most natural looking moves you know the
like Bishop G5 develop the rest of your
pieces and just
continue normally I mean at the same
time it's not like the position is this
position is super complicated it's just
a normal Black's wasting a lot of time
with this queen it's not like a sicilian
reverse castling so I didn't
wasn't worried that much but I was more
worried that the game would just be
there out to complete equality
um
yeah it depends uh what kind of position
but uh
the white is supposed to be slightly
better here
um yeah I don't know maybe bishop B5 is
good uh yeah I think I remember looking
a little something like this but white
I've made different options like Bishop
D6 Bishop G3
where do you feel that your opponent
went wrong
ah well the date Knight G4 with a bad
move
very cool but I thought maybe Rook C1
was not good I was thinking like he
should take the pawn E4 but instead Rook
V1 maybe I should take first on C6
and there's a different Factory because
after Rook C1
I think black cannot like if Rook V1
here I think black can no longer take
the pawn because of Knight H4
maybe I should have taken them Queen E6
through E1 unless I'm missing something
seems like black is losing a beef
F5 F5 and G5 maybe yeah F5 and G5 huh
yeah but scary back to play yeah G5
Knight F5 yeah
and you defeated right away
I remember he said he had all these
tactical problems posted on the walls
after training I mean I'm a big fan of
G5 but there are limits
yeah so I probably played Rook V1 way
too quickly because I was
I wanted to watch the Armageddon game
avicaro
so maybe I should have taken for it
because here black I think can take on
e4
and the point is after Knight H4 he's
got Queen G5 or something
yeah I mean G5
attacking my Bishop a big difference
and you mentioned 94 was a mistake were
you pretty confident after that yeah it
looked so bad and the same crazy
you don't think you are yeah I don't
know G4 looks so bad like I don't know
where his preparation went wrong but I
think
no they back ever since it's dominating
performance in like and say if
struggling a little bit I guess if not
he's a fantastic player and
it's very tactical and you know he plays
like a machine
but at the same time you know for very
young players are still struggling to
find their footing in professional life
I thought this end game looks completely
well lost for black like I was very
happy when I got this I got rid of all
the nasty pieces the Queens the Bishops
the knights but
[Laughter]
I mean I knew I could I know there's a
good chance I could always mess this up
but this position looks like one zero to
me because F4 bring the king
and The Rook from A5
apparently computer gives one and a half
F6 so I think after F6
maybe it doesn't really have a good F6
Rook C7
Rook F7 takes takes ef6
I thought this last chance was King
takes F6
and then try to
Rook D5
Rook the eight and Rook B4 yeah yeah
exactly
repeat B3
Rook B4
then not much hope though no
King F1 King effects
and then okay five okay five okay two
King D3 will be seven King E2 yeah yeah
if I can't win this game then I'll never
ever win a game
very impressive but uh let's move on to
the bird's eye view because we have
still two classical games ongoing uh one
game of course between Magnus and
alireza well first of all what did you
think of the opening between these two
yeah that Magnus removed
I don't know is it your idea
it seems like the bishop moved to a few
squares or too many squares that Bishop
E2 makes a lot more sense but yeah I
think maybe Magnus just didn't prepare
at all today woke up an hour before the
game just decided to play whatever I
mean he couldn't have expected alireza
to play the Sicilian with E6 in any case
because Alias has been playing mostly E5
uh or from Knight dorf I think well he
hasn't played neither for in a while but
I I couldn't have predicted to fill in
with E6 so
I know what Bishop did there is about
but incidentally you read Magnus right
because he went to the confessional and
he said you know he wasn't hadn't
predicted the Sicilian with E6 and so he
just was like okay I'm gonna freestyle
it I'm playing Bishop D3 oh yeah but he
couldn't he knew this idea beforehand
like he's seen some games maybe he's
played some practice games maybe it's
David's idea
I mean no one in the right mind would I
mean no one would ever find Bishop
Dieter over the board but so that's
what's my idea
crazy also by playing G5 which if either
better or worse or black but I thought
G5 was a very good move like black is
starting to take over but things fell
apart so quickly like I'm sure black off
so many
many more better ways to try to equal
life like maybe the D5 on move three I
don't know
did you kind of assume that Magnus would
win this early on uh because Hikaru
joined us and he said already moved 11
12. Magnus is going to win even though
the evaluation was roughly level well
what was the position move 11. oh but we
have action action on the board
he had to do something right yeah
he doesn't do anything
the bishop on The Queen Is Almost
trapped on on A4 like probably yeah I
mean I probably would would play the
chicken Queen B3
and get off all that you have to make
sure you don't ever get mated
it's not good to make a thing
I mean physics is falling
I always play it too Wesley
engine doesn't like it you play Queen A6
and grab the phone
well actually on the live board Magnus
also again follows your advice simplify
the position get the Queens off I like
it yeah like I would play Queen beat
every single day but I don't expect
Magnus to play it so quickly I think
it's of psychological if you're playing
on the clock I mean yesterday you almost
lost one time he had half a second but
he was winning almost
before
um oh yeah he was winning when the
Bishops got traded or just Queen F4 very
surprised that he he missed that
actually TV2 did a bit of analysis on
that he had 0.24 seconds left Magnus
when he made the move
0.24 seconds oh wow yeah
I was standing right there he just
totally for forgot about his time I
thought he was gonna lose
like if I screamed or jump or did
anything like this
he would lose for sure and I remember
maybe uh not good idea to repeat but
maybe like 15 years ago we used to have
international opens in the Philippines
and then one of the Filipinos was
playing chess Grandmaster and tracker on
a third five seconds he just said down
that happened to me once too in one of
my first International tournaments in
Gibraltar my opponent was like you lost
on time and I looked at it I had like
three two one and I was like wait I
could have yeah I lost yeah because I
was so freaked out I was so shocked yeah
but yeah I was rooting for yesterday so
I didn't do anything
you mentioned some of the other games
Wesley have you been keeping an eye on
all the other action watching the
armageddon's uh during the rounds
uh for sure yeah the damn to me the day
I watch all the Armageddon game uh
because yeah it was surprising
um not sure if hikar was playing safe
today or he just wants to
um that's this opening maybe he kind of
wanted both you know it because I was
looking at the same line last night
really yeah
accepted I also played the Queens can be
accepted and this game was uh played by
mad theme in Poland he's been playing a
lot of that lately and he loves to do
the queen sacrifice do the play Rook A4
fabric A6 and uh
who was it all for anishiki replayed it
in Romania so so I was looking at the
same line last night but the computer
was giving like 0.20 after okay six so I
knew it was a draw at some point but
um yeah
but is that your style to kind of play
these very complicated
openings which I've all been analyzed
out or do you prefer a different
approach to the opening no I think I
think it's if the trend is this uh
I I don't like memorizing too much like
I don't like the civilian night or for
weight of 15 drive and move six
or yeah I don't like all this opposite
castling
positions
so the Queens can be accepted is a very
good choice because
I think one of the reasons everyone's
playing it because they're so little
critical lines there's so few critical
lines compared to the grunfeld for
example and I I think Ian neponia told
once mentioned to me that
uh the grand felt they had to study like
three openings at some point because
there's just so much Theory so it's nice
to
go for it for a change for a while also
my good friend Lanier Dominguez have
been playing it against me so many times
I think we had like eight throws
after he made all those I played with
black the flame yeah you know what they
say if you can't beat them join them
yeah yeah exactly I guess Anish is
winning very
e Philly yeah it should be very easy win
I guess there was no way for oriented
trade the Rooks ever
and uh out of curiosity one of the
special things about Norway chess is
that confessionals have you ever been
tempted to enter the booth and confess
your thoughts yeah I mean I did twice
laugh here but I don't exactly know what
to say I mean I could be like a current
just bash everyone's position
that would be funny if you would share
it that ah Nakamura has I just looked at
it yesterday
yeah I didn't I didn't think of that but
if you don't want to reveal any secret
of your game just look at the others
very good idea huh maybe maybe one day
but any tips on what to say
whatever comes to mind we just share
your opening thoughts or middle game
what will be the end of the the score of
the games for example predictions yeah
predictions for example magnus's game I
mean if you would see G5 on the board
more move five
I like that yeah for sure maybe yeah
they never gave us tips about what to
say during professional food but he
certainly okay anyway thank you very
much Wesley for joining us in the studio
and keeping us all entertained and
congratulations on your win you're now
number third in the standings
yeah it's very nice to know I can still
win a game at the end like 14 classical
draws in a row so as I found the
interview earlier
the only thing I hate more than drawing
is losing a game so
it's always an issue like you wanna you
want to
win games but at the same time it's hard
to get a position that's
uh
uh you know where you get too many
chances so I could always use a tip on
that maybe do it again
I mean today I don't remember already I
retired from comparative chess nine
years ago this game nowadays it's a
different sport
yeah I think I think it's like it's like
basketball like I'm watching the NBA
Finals I think that the game just
changed a lot in the last 10 years I
think my mom thinks that there will be
more and more rapid and live games
uh and she keeps saying that
there are no new classical tournaments
coming up I mean what you have if what's
always been around and there have been a
few that disappeared like Bilbao or
Dortmund or Alpha London I mean what
happened there so maybe rapidly this is
the future in Jeff but the classical
Still Remains my favorite so we'll see
so you like this format here no HS
Wesley
it was hard to
I think
maybe one idea if you can lower the time
control for the classical and then put
the Blitz game first before an immediate
Armageddon it's hard I mean the system
is not perfect but at the same time it's
very exciting
I I think the point system doesn't make
too much sense to me because you get
three points for a win but if you draw
the players split the two and a half
Point difference with mathematically it
doesn't
make too much
fence
um and also it's very tiring for the
players because you're playing two games
every day
and maybe it makes sense to just sleep
all day not prepare at all and that's
the like what Magnus did so so the
system is not perfect but certainly it
makes very exciting I mean yeah I don't
watch an entire classical four-hour
match but I will watch an Armageddon
absolutely and on that note Wesley once
again thank you so much for joining us
and good luck for the remaining rounds
thank you
so we see Anish and tari on the screen
theory is going to be squeezed in this
game
yeah it looks like the squeeze has been
going on for a while Judah and it could
well end in a mating attack Black's King
is stuck on the edge of the board we
could see a niche convert this Advantage
any moment now it looks like black has
been forced to jettison a second pawn
and barring any crazy stalemates
it looks like uh yeah this result's
almost secured now we said it was
difficult in Practical terms and
unfortunately for Terry it's just that
kind of tournament especially when the
clocks have been ticking down a bit of
panic setting in and yeah just against
these top guys you only need to give
them one chance and they'll take it well
now I guess Geary is thinking about is
G5 going to lead to a mate
or should I just captured the pawn on F5
I would try to look at how it's going to
be after G5
yes with very different Judith me too
I'm just curious that can might give a
Checkmate I don't know after G5 King H5
Rook uh h8
is there is there any practical
idea behind it I think you might be
right this is probably just a Checkmate
but Ivanka I thought the pawn Grabber in
you would want to just simply take on F1
no I did want to take on F5
there was no calculation involved
whatsoever for me I did see G5 and I
thought well maybe that might lead to
let mate but you know put it in the bank
as I say and take the pawn and
when he wants to win beautifully however
Anish uh should we quickly jump in judic
show these checkmating attacks that
you're going for let's see if it works
I'm not sure it works check engage five
first of all don't retreat this is
Checkmate the black king on G7 trapped
uh so King H5 as you say Rook h8 hitting
the pawn I have to play H6 I guess I can
throw in a check but you can just uh
grab a pawn before running back
I think you can take this one safely yes
that's what's the plan just H6 and now
technically
so what about Rook G8
try to Leo me away I will not take your
Rook yeah you will move away to C6 right
yep I'll move somewhere
the question now finishing G6 H6 yeah
this is probably just more than
sufficient
now I cannot play Rook takes H6 just to
show another pretty checkmating pattern
the lawnmower checkmate instead yeah I
mean I can give a couple of checks but
you just run the white king is super
safe
and surely sooner or later this Pawn
will promote how do you get the Rooks
out the way
well maybe
maybe but maybe there is just no way to
defend Black's position
yeah maybe white just plays it slowly G3
yeah
and then uh G4
Rook H3
well probably everything wins that's the
problem for blood
and of course what you you guys said GTX
F5 just to grab the pawn it is very
tempting
just want to build a protective shell
around the white king just about three
E4 exactly whatever it comes to B4 we
just go E4 as you are highlighted and
you are two pawns up you're preparing
yourself for a rook trade
yeah so will Anish go for Glory will he
try Checkmate basically he wants to
calculate everything I think because
Atari has three minutes left on the
clock but the Anish also has not so much
time going down under five minutes
but this is an interesting question here
because we were having a conversation
about perfectionism
so Anish you know he has a four and a
half minutes
it doesn't get any added time until he
hits move 41 which he will do but it
will only be 10 seconds
yeah is it more practical just to grab
the pawn and just say you know what
easy chest there or should he spend that
time and try to work out the most
correct solution
usually I'd say invest the time why not
but four minutes when there's such a
kind of easy obvious alternative I don't
know Judith well
to go down until three minutes let's say
but that's all the time he has I think
okay go down to three and then decide
and they say there are different types
of chess player there are artists
accountants I'm the accountant just take
the project just add up all the points
there and you win the game uh but he
wants the artistic flair out of
delivering Checkmate and yeah I think
you're right Judy he'll spend another 30
seconds one minute and then we'll see a
move
the decision on that subject all the
different types of chess players I I was
told by the late daveretsky he said the
English chess players they fall into two
categories they're either scientists or
mathematicians
or
or he called them street thugs
another fight
G5 G5 on the board but I think it's not
gonna mate but after King H5 Rook h8 H6
if you can show it on the board maybe
white just wants to go Rook f8
attack the pawn on F7 and then simplify
it with Rook H6
collect uh you see this manner ah no
sorry I thought it's on the board but
it's only on our board yeah it's only on
our board so this is the current live
position he has just played Rook h8
threatening Checkmate in two moves by
capturing on H7 trapping the black king
and of course
yeah multiple ways to fall on your sword
here if you Retreat this Rook to G7 then
the other Rook can just simply drop back
there's going to be meeting ideas here
on H6 so we are expecting H6 as the most
kind of Tenacious defense here the only
way to keep the game going okay
nice
I'm just a look can we go back to the
bedside very because this looks really
good for white can we just go back to
the alireza Magnus game because look at
that bar
this is there something wrong with that
bar oh it's like as chat says what did
Magnus do
what did Magnus do indeed uh wow this
game has changed he's no longer simply a
piece up for two pawns Suddenly It's a
rook for Bishop and Knight and both
sides have passed pawns if white doesn't
promote his seatbon
38 seconds for firoza
it looks easier to play with white at
least you just push your Pawn to C7 and
hope for the best but
okay farooja fighting so is there some
like Rook h8 idea with Rook H2 and and
the white king can't escape whoa
wow could that be the idea Ivanka as you
say go for counter play against the
white king Magnus instantly C7 pushing
his pawn and Moment of Truth ricochet
how's this working King going to hide
you might have to go walk about if
Magnus wants to win this game and his
technique has been lacking you've got to
say this tournament
even if he wins this game you will think
there must have been smoother ways to do
it
Wesley set himself trading the Queens
you know uh the minimalist approach but
it might have backfired the obvious move
it's on the board Rook h8 with 26
seconds left
so how can
well if Rook B1 the problem is for a
white I believe that Rook H2 check
ing goes up the other route comes to
check and after King F4 black can go
King G6
and there is a rook F2 mate opportunity
so actually black is maybe not
threatening right now much maybe E3 can
be the next move if it would be black to
move
yeah Magnus is King in some big trouble
suddenly White's Bishop which was so
kind of uh yeah it was just the best
piece on the board Suddenly It's not
contributing White's Bishop just staring
into thinner it's all about the white
king the black Rooks getting around
getting active maybe this is what Magnus
missed this maneuver just uh kind of
vacating squares getting the two black
Rooks lined up
okay three minutes against 26 seconds
yeah but three results are possible here
absolutely but the thing is though
ferrugia's plan is so straightforward
whereas how is Magnus ever going to
promote his Pawn
you have to look after the king
and this is frustrated
rightly so he knows what he's done
dismissed something
would you even play here it's incredible
right he had such a commanding position
and now it's just wild as David said
yeah I mean there's three passports for
black yeah
and the white king is unsafe well he
does make a move with his Knight big
threat of Knight to d8 check and alireza
did you see him bang out that move give
a check King has to run
wow and Magnus is walking forward into
the lion's den
no checkmates on the white king yet but
alireza simply taking another Pawn
watching the White Sea Pawn from behind
this time
okay but now check and takes the pawn on
E6
and look look look at the bar it is
creeping in Black's flavor whoa
oh my God
white king in huge huge trouble what
happens if you take on E6 with that
white knight is there a Checkmate maybe
simply Rook Jack and after King F4 E3
he's reaching for that pawn and Rook C4
check mate he's threatening there
Magnus is gambled but it's gonna
backfire and far Asia still has enough
time to think ferger really thrives in
these calculation type of positions
Knight takes E6 you've just got to play
at Magnus no alternative now Rook H3 and
D3
okay he gives that track he's gonna play
the move you mentioned that you did I
think
but can't erase a check on F3 as you've
kind of take the Rooks off and then take
the Rooks off and then push your pawns
and we're being told that Rook F3 is the
only move to save this game if black
pushes forward with E3 maybe white can
give a knight check and
it gets crazy still wow Rook F3 the only
move to keep the balance will ferusia
find it only 25 seconds and he plays it
with 20 something 30 seconds on the
clock
yeah Rick's off the board
which way to capture back that's the
question
G Pawn E Pawn E Pawn I have the
intuition
he does two first same Instinct and uh
take a look at Fabiana caruana in chat
saying we're all buzzed during these
games
ah shout out to Fabi why aren't you here
with us we need help understanding
unpicking this game because it looks
like anything but a draw Black's pawns
running
yeah it's a race well F2 is a huge
threat I mean how is white gonna cope
with that by stepping back with the King
but then you'll
at the risk of getting checkmated
worst time to blunder
I don't understand the evaluation but I
was in the center a moment ago but black
simply has this huge threat it's black
not just winning with F2 F4 F1 Queen
simply can't stop it as white
what is the idea here
block with your Bishop maybe but you
still push with F2 yeah and the poor
black will promote the with a check
and he who checks first wins
wow and Fabi again telling us that this
is not an ideal result it certainly
isn't and uh it's incredible yeah for
the standings for me we'll make up some
ground on Fabi
well Magnus I would have put a lot of
money Hikaru said it himself Magnus is
going to win this game he's going to
close it out and he had an extra piece
simply
10 minutes later
losing position well he went under one
minute very hard to decide what move he
can do
is he going to play Bishop C5
he looks like he was reaching for his
King is he going to step back to the
king G3 it says but then Rook G2 check
and uh King G3 it does allow an under
promotion Checkmate
that is beautiful from Fabi I think we
might have to show that on the board I
mean while Magnus looks disgusted with
himself looking away from the board
okay a rook check from farusha first of
all and King H4 was this a slip was this
I think it was I think he's going for a
draw for a show because suddenly white
is about to make a new Queen you don't
have time to go back
okay we're being told that F2 was the
only winning move in foruga you can tell
on the body language
yeah shaking his head now and we'll see
this position repeat itself crazy stuff
neither side can play for a win without
too much risk here and
draw
wow
typical game where both players can be
unhappy right
so many twists and turns where to even
start I mean it was the tales of the
unexpected it looked like complete
one-way traffic for Magnus he looked
completely overwhelming and then
we tune in
of Ali Reza has turned it around it's
like Mission Impossible and now
I think Magnus now demonstrating a win
this underpromotion Checkmate that uh
Fabiana caruana in chat big shout out to
Fabi did mention yeah so much to unpack
from that game and the player's still
discussing it as they get ready for that
Armageddon we should mention another
result has ticked in now Anish Guru did
convert his advantage against ariantari
as expected and just to show the closing
stages the final moves of this game
because it did look like Magnus Carlsen
after So Many Adventures was crashing
down to defeat he takes F3 with the
correct move King to back to G3 and F2
would have been the Bone Crusher here
promoting to a knight if white uh for
example let's say makes a new Queen then
suddenly a night promotion uh and this
king is getting checkmated look at this
no matter where the King goes it gets
checkmated either on F4 or on H4 this
would have been a beautiful finish but
after F2 King G2 was the move yeah this
would have put Alaris off
and then G3 I guess G3 and Black's Rook
is simply coming down uh coming across
and Rook C1 F1 Queen would have won the
game for furugia
wow dramatic stuff just not enough time
to calculate through all the
complications there
either side well what a mess Opportunity
by Magnus in this game and it seems like
there is really one way
no question that he's going to be
winning what a save by alireza but a big
help from Magnus yeah when it rains it
pause and at the moment Magnus simply
can't win a classical game no matter how
hard he tries so close though in that
one
oh more chest though for us that'll be a
treat
well well that was such a dramatic
moment and it's the perfect time for us
to take a break as we anticipate the
next Armageddon between Magnus Carlson
and alireza farisa so don't go away
we have Magnus carlsen's most incredible
moments as world champion this one right
here is vishwanathan with the white
pieces versus Magnus Carlson in 2013.
here we go so this is uh Nims on Indian
same as variation right and the last
move here was B3 from Magnus just saying
hey man I'm trying to Queen this pawn
and of course Anan is saying I'm trying
to Major game cool you can get your
little queen I'm just gonna try to check
nature right so of course this is a
hints to move uh F5 B3
and he's like cool well if it's one of
the non says hey okay you can get this
queen I'm gonna try to go for me so he
goes Queen F4 you get another piece in
the game this looks very very dangerous
here
then what the heck is going on night to
see somebody thought it'd be something
spectacular he was like yeah I'm waiting
for this one but it's just Knight to C7
defensive move cool allows F6 to happen
here F6 is going to take on G7 it's
gonna be kind of annoying scary things
happening with Knight H5 Magnus plays G6
okay it's locked up it's gonna be scary
if a queen gets to H6 also if the queen
in a rook get to the H file it's gonna
be a wrap for black here Magnus is going
to be mated Okay cool so Magnus
understands that Vichy announced as she
understands that too and plays Queen to
H4 where is he going class eight six
right he's about to make he's also
trying to get the Rook over here too as
well okay cool with that being said your
move what do you do now it's black to
move
here's the move hence Knight C7 to put
the Knight on EA the saying goes a
knight on E8 is actually f8 the x is
what they say there is no mate a knight
understands this he said oh there's no
mermaid that's cool I'm gonna put my
queen right here
what I'm trying to do is bring the Rook
up to F3 or F4 and actually go for this
main 087 because you stopped the G7 made
that's cool
perfect well Magnus understands this so
what does Magnus do in this position
black to move
here it is Magnus says cool you want
mate okay that's cool that's cool go for
it B2 do your thing big fella go ahead
wanted on so he says okay I will
Young fella Rook F4 he goes here and
he's going for Rook H for me wow is this
scary why are you gonna get your queen
you did all of this are you gonna get
your queen or not
of course we are B1 Queen right after B1
Queen Knight to F1 from Hanan and the
move the move here that seals the deal
is what guys there's two Queens on the
board Magnus has two queens but is he
getting mated or not it's black to move
he goes
cleaning one and then the game is over
the game ended right here believe it or
not there is no more PGN right what do
you mean Queenie what how what what what
what what sense does that make well
let's see what happens the idea here you
have to Queen E1 where were you putting
your Rook H4 well I can just go Rook H4
but guess what after I capture it Queen
sacrifice sacrificing one of my two
queens after Queen takes H4 let's do a
peace count you have a queen you have a
bishop and a knight I have a queen a
bishop a knight and a rook ice so after
that this is done right I have an extra
piece an extra rook and there's no mate
here so that's a resignation and Magnus
wins that's incredible right
laughs
[Music]
foreign
hello and welcome back I'm the chess
Adventure Continues because we just had
a very hair raising game between Magnus
Carlsen and Ali Reza faruza it did end
in a draw
and there were a lot of Adventures along
the way but this all means that an
approximately seven minutes we are going
to see our final Armageddon of the night
and that game was so crazy so
mind-blowing on so many different ways
should we have a recap of those last few
moves just to kind of get our heads
around what exactly happened I'd love to
so if we bring up the board we can see
what was really going on if we can
understand a bit of it even that will be
a challenge student it was such a wild
game and uh we left it when we were with
Wesley so a bit earlier after black
sacrificed a piece we thought out of
desperation more than anything Bishop
takes F4 giving up the bishop at least
activating the Knight and here Wesley
said okay this scared move would be
Queen B3 actually Magnus did play this
maybe keeping the Queens on the board
would have been the more practical try
because Black's Queen is so sidelined
right now but after the queen trade we
saw a few more moves from both sides
very logical stuff and it was here after
a night check the Black Knight
regrouping and landing on e4 that Magnus
maybe let it slip Judah in the brick we
were discussing why did Magnus give up
his Rook for this night well I think
it's interesting to point out if you
look at it in the last three moves black
from F4 his Knight was brought to E4
relocating it in a much better Square
through H3 G5 E4 and now creating an
idea which is kind of scary that black
can go Rook to H3 with a check on G3
possibly in a Perpetual check but even
if things go very wrong black and go
King F7 and even the other Rook can show
up on the H file so probably this made
Magnus think that okay I don't want to
deal with this Knight on e4 but maybe
with accurate play maybe there is still
some winning advantage and this is why
chess is so interesting nowadays also
because I'm sure the engine will say
it's plus 5.3 if you make the only good
moves the winning moves then of course
it's very simple and easy and it's easy
to say ah it's just the winning position
we don't even have to look at it because
it's done it's cooked of course if you
see a Magnus in good form I think it
should be the case as well when the
engine says that it's plus five or we
see a winning position he's going to be
converting his Advantage but here
something went wrong
yeah something went wrong and he decided
to take this Knight off the board no
longer needing needing to deal with any
of those night folks night jumps but
suddenly I think this is the plan that
Magnus had underestimated after he
stepped back with his Knight just Rook
to H3 and now King to F7 freeing up the
other black Rook to come to h8 and join
its fellow here and suddenly enough
count to play for black because it
seemed very good worldwide that he he
brings her back the night and probably
he also thought that covering the F3
square is going to be enough in the
defense and his pawns is going to be
pushed and it's just uh cannot be
stopped but King F7 and Rook h8 it made
it possible for black to give very
strong counter chances giving check on
H2 and the other Rook can also brought
to H3 and possible Checkmate ideas also
if if we can see the line for example
a white goes C7 Rook h8
and let's say white goes I don't know 90
Knight C6 for example was this the game
Knight C6 yeah
no we were talking if not Knight C6 if
Rook B1 for example
so that's what I would like to show then
Rook H2 King G3 Rook 8 to H3 King F4 and
if rookie F2 then king would be sneaking
out on G5 but black can play King G6 and
in the next move Rook F2 mate is a
threat so white does not have time to
clean the pawn
and uh but maybe Knight F5 is possible
yeah maybe just Rook F1 as well coming
back to defend or Rook F1 coming back to
the defense yeah this would have been uh
yeah really crazy line and I think we
saw something equally crazy in the game
you said it dude at Knight C6 instead
the threatening 98 check followed by
making a new Queen and counter play from
verucia Rook H2 and he took this Pawn
and this was where Magnus did blunder
actually he played a losing move Knight
to dhek very natural one but maybe the
only move to keep the balance difficult
and I'm not sure I would have found it
with no time on the clock Rook H1
[Music]
C3 right yeah the idea is to deflect
this black Rook away so we can make a
new Queen but so difficult to spot
sacrifices like that and as you
mentioned Judith uh most likely the game
would have ended in a draw here instead
we saw a draw in a crazy away and okay
they're off it's Armageddon it is
Armageddon Magna starts with 10 minutes
on the clock alireza has seven minutes
and remember Magnus playing with the
white pieces is in a must win situation
the players will get a one second move
increment once they pass move 41 and oh
look at that
on the board with a sense of humor
putting his Bishop on D3 for the second
time today in front of its own Depot and
now we know the inspiration behind
magnus's opening choice in the first
classical game he clearly prepared this
line against the Petrov and he thought
okay Bishop D3 there wasn't bad why not
play it against the Sicilian but uh this
is the Petrov there have been a trade of
e-pawns and it's just a question about
whether white is able to generate enough
activity with his extra move here in a
symmetrical position well this is not a
nice thing from Fairuza to play the
Petro which is so drawy sometimes and we
would wanted to see something G5 and
firework in this game also but it seems
like firoz is so happy to get away in
the classical game that he says okay
draw brings me the brings the victory in
our magadon so let's be very solid
wow and black looks Rock Solid I'm
really surprised by magnus's opening
approach in a must-win situation uh
needing to win with white for the points
here because he's allowed some trades
already shout out to Eric Rosen in the
chat he says oh no Stafford Gambit
yeah no staff at Gambit unfortunately at
this level not yet at least maybe in the
last round if aikaru needs to beat
Fabiano for tournament Victory there we
will see an opening like that one but
okay what do you think Judith any
chances for white to create an advantage
well Magnus has to create something the
question is whether where is he going to
bring the bishop to develop is he going
to play B3 and Bishop B2 or Bishop to E3
or F4 later but for the moment he goes
Queen B3 attacking the B7 Pawn
seven swiftly defended Queen C8
yeah black is a bit cramped you've got
to say maybe D5 and Knight D4 is a very
typical way of continuing the fight and
it's on the void you call it Judith you
predict it and white tonight is going to
find a beautiful Outpost or before
square at least on D4 gaining time in
the process
and you think Magnus will keep visas on
oh wow he trades off creates a very
strong deep on here for himself makes a
lot of sense because now we've
reaching C5 and Rook C1 and Rook D1
white has a very nice position so this
is why Knight D7 immediately trying to
block the opportunity for white to go C5
yeah black snow wants to come around to
C5 itself and hit this White Queen
and yeah both players playing extremely
faster up to this point Magnus has
maintained his time Advantage three
extra minutes I think rookie one is a
sensible move
but he goes Rook C1 and after Knight C5
I believe he wants to bring back the
queen to D1 and later play B4
it makes a lot of sense there's so many
ways that Magnus can expand with his
pawns and uh Ali was actually playing B6
yeah weakening some squares but at least
holding up the advance of White's Queen
side majority there is going to be
extremely difficult for Magnus to get
that C5 break in a bit later he's gonna
have to regroup his pieces it's going to
take a slower Pace now the game okay
first he jumps
I want to play C5 you're not going to
stop that
and I like the way alireza discussed you
be my guest I'm waiting for that
and here it is on the board
wow I've got to say I'm surprised Magnus
just going Route One super direct here
with C5 this is going to lead to a bunch
of Peace trades but he's arguing that uh
with his extra deep Pawn here in the
center he's cramping down uh Black's
position and black has some isolated
pawns on the queen side well right now
it's not so easy there but he's going to
be moving his Queen because the B2 Pawn
has to be defended so Queen A3 seems to
be the best move for that but you don't
want to enter into the pin right
Queen A3 you walk into that pin and it
might take a while to break that tension
so what to do if you step across to the
C file then after a bunch of exchanges a
bunch of trades on C5 the black Rook is
simply going to gobble up that pawn of
B2 but after all maybe it is possible to
go Queen to C3 let's say and if
everything is exchanged on C5 and Rook
captures the B2 D6 might be the move and
the great
counter-attack Magnus does not move his
Queen out of the eye line of the Black
Brook instead Bishop A6 hitting the
black queen
chaos for the first time in this game
wow
clever move creative move it is very
clever but I'm guessing that farrugia
obviously can't touch the White Queen
has to just move his Queen anywhere that
protects the Knight on D7
yeah and the question is here if firstly
you can move the queen as you say uh
Ivanka can we take this Knight off the
board because it protects the white
Bishop who protects the White Queen and
from there the Knight is jumping to take
the White Queen there's a lot of
calculation to be done suddenly
yes which is usually something that you
don't have time for in Armageddon but he
must really eight because
he wants to keep the Queens on the board
Knight B7 I would think and uh you can
see that move did not meet with the
computer's approval it's been awarded
a question mark a 1976 there and look at
the A7 weakness exactly oh that pawn
keeps dropping off in every game every
day we see Bishop takes A7 somehow
happened Hikaru played it in his game uh
I think we've seen it in various stages
and wow big threat as you say to it
not easy to deal with white pieces look
clumsy this is a pin a self-imposed pin
but for now white has full control
serious problems are opposed to alireza
I think right now
we should mention Magnus is on five out
of five in his Armageddon he's won every
single one so far in this tournament
could it be six in a row
You Can't Win In classical but
Armageddon nothing uh no one can stop
him nothing going wrong there well
actually these days he's more happy to
play short and in time controls it seems
and he also expresses this View and well
the result here shows reflects that
quite a bit
wow he's really invading the black Camp
the black territory here Rook C6 look at
that Bishop Knight Rook for white just
entrenched in the black queen side and
not easy for farusha to deal with this
Knight takes Bishop the White Knight
taking the black dark Square Bishop
maybe a threat to win a pawn
yeah to God after God against that one
fruit is all tied up
yeah it's not so easy to look for
counter chances for black queen E7 may
be protecting the D6
Bishop but also after that it seems like
white can probably take on D6 and then
grab the B6 Knight and it's going to
cost a pawn for black yeah I wonder
whether there are also options of maybe
retreating the bishop all the way back
to C8 just to ask some questions to the
night and hopefully Bank on some
activity after that I think white should
be capturing the Knight first on B6 and
only after that to capture the D6 then
black still is losing material
now black is likely going to lose a pawn
no matter what so farisha just has to
find a version in which he's active in
which he can throw questions to Magnus
clock times not in his favor down under
three minutes now still a long long time
before he gets that valuable Priceless
one second increment
it's going to be a struggle to even get
there at this point and he Retreats the
Knight back to C8 with the idea of
capturing
and still his well farisha's pawns are
just a disaster there on the queen side
but perhaps furuji can generate some
play on the king side once a white moves
the queen why has the Beloved Bishop
here it feels like if Magnus can weather
the storm and not allow any counter play
those white Bishops are going to clean
up just need to move the queen first
attacked by the black Rook yeah this is
the question where white is moving the
queen I think in the next move somehow
black wants to go Bishop to E4 in the
center and attack probably the D5 Pawn
because for now the G2 pressure is not
much but I can imagine I can imagine
that black goes Bishop E4 F5 Queen G6
and looking for counter chances
okay and Magnus slides over to C3 very
safe Square you'll move on the board you
that you need some counter play and he
survived the worst position than this
already today for Russia so he will be
feeling optimistic if he can whip up
some activity
what's Magnus gonna do okay you're on A7
I can take this Pawn he can take the
pawn on C7 he has done
look C7 first
now the black queen has Avenues in
between A4 you want to say yeah first
move that comes to mind and he plays it
activity over everything here
hitting the white light Square Bishop at
the same time Bishop can come back to F1
where it's extremely safe and defends
everything the back Rank and the G2
Square
played on the board it is played but the
A2 Pawn is dropping but there is an E5
Pawn can drop
A7
um we're gonna see that because that's
exactly what's happened in the game and
the problem is for black if Queen D5
takes takes then Rook D7 and the piece
is going to be falling off for firoza
you cannot take that white Pawn on D5
you lose a piece you get skewered at the
end there and farusha shaking his head
for the first time in this game but how
does he maintain the piece I don't think
he can I think he's missed this I think
he was banking on the fact that he
played Queen takes porn but this will
not work and while farisa stops the
clock and resigns
yeah Magnus once again takes an
Armageddon Victory and Nets one and a
half points and there you see the two
players smiling analyzing
but what an dominating performance by
Magnus in the Armageddon match
it was abrupt to the Finish there but he
was always in control Magnus
Jude nice technique well very nice I I
didn't think that the author of The
Petra of it will be so easy or seemingly
so easy to make the victory for Magnus
but it all started when he came out with
the queen I think and he started to
develop his pieces pushing it when it
was impossible for him to exchange the
knights and then the sea Pawn was pushed
that's where everything started to go on
the side of Magnus
and that we see the players discussing
Magnus pointed to his head as if he
missed something but it felt like he
always had things under control and yeah
it's been two fascinating games between
these two guys
they got it close so much drama
oh there are a lot of Dramas in these
two games but in the classical more yeah
this is true starting out from move
three
until the last move Bishop D3 is going
to become a trend
you heard it here first and uh just to
recap today's score it went to
Armageddon between Magnus Carlton and
Ali Reza faroogia but it was Magnus
Carlsen that did walk away with the
Armageddon Victory and an important win
in the classical game for Wesley so
against nordbeck Abdul sotorov and in
other decisive results Anish Geary is
actually netting three points but
perhaps surprising was Fabiana caruana
losing in the Armageddon game against
goo cash
yeah in that game it was very
interesting to see how go cash was
balancing it out in the classical game
he didn't have too much of a problem we
felt that there was one or two moment
where he had to be very accurate to make
a draw and then in the Armageddon
everything went on the side of Fabiano
that he really had a good game he built
it up he had the winning position but we
can see go cash the young New Hope in
the world that possibly a future will
Champion we can say he shows his skills
that he's fighting until the very end
and he was in our studio telling much in
advance that he saw this opportunity of
saving the game possibly putting his
Queen from F7 eventually in the corner
of White's gum on A1 and possibly saving
the game and he could execute it and he
saved the game so he won the match he
did on just his wits I mean that was an
impressive result an impressive save
from kukash and for you day fit him is
so much excitement so much excitement we
do have two kings of Armageddon we
should mention Magnus now on six wins
out of six Armageddon gamesh four wins
out of five Armageddon games impressive
but it was the classical games that uh
also uh made an impression today the
standings however they have opened up
slightly compared to yesterday with two
rounds to go there was a lot of movement
in the standings after those two
classical victories actually looked like
things could even change even more
significantly but uh still at the top is
Fabiana carono with 14 and a half points
out of 21. Hikaru Nakamura just two
points behind with 12 and a half points
and now new name and number three Wesley
so after his classical win does rise up
to ten and a half points out of 21. two
rounds left Anything could happen
between these three it's all about those
victories those points in the classical
games
oh
I think this is setting things up so
nicely for the final two rounds we are
in for a treat and let's have a look at
Thursday's matchups remember tomorrow is
a free day for the players and for
ourselves and this time chakra mamajarov
will be facing off against Magnus
Carlson and for Fabiana carono he meets
Wesley so wow what do you guys think
about these matches
oh
well it's going to be incredible the
next game after the free day but well
what would I pick uh well of course it's
always interesting to see Magnus but uh
uh I still want to see the the
youngsters how they can continue their
way up yeah definitely the youngsters
are really taking points a few David
yeah for me it's going to be about
whether Hikaru can continue the chase of
Fabi uh we had him in the studio today
it was fascinating to hear his thought
processes that it feels like he needs to
take some risks but after the rest day
he plays Abdul sotorov who also loves uh
fire on the board so it's going to be
fascinating yes sir definitely we are
certainly lined up for a lot of
Adventure and as the pieces settle on
the chessboard after an eventful day we
now look forward to a rest day we're
gonna enjoy that one very much and we
will see you on Thursday same time same
place 5 p.m Central European Time so
thank you all for watching and see you
then
thank you
foreign
[Music]